foreign
hi everyone welcome to yet another video
tutorial on the top 10 reasons to learn
python in 2022
Python's popularity has grown
exponentially over the past few years
and is being widely used in different
jobs
so this video will focus on the
different reasons why it is important to
learn python in 2022 let's begin
the first reason we have is python is
versatile
python is a totally versatile language
as it has been used widely in artificial
intelligence data science machine
learning web development embedded
systems graphic design applications data
mining gaming and others
python is used as an easier and more
effectively written alternative to
languages that perform similar
functionalities like art and Java
now talking about the second reason why
you should learn python in 2022 we have
python is the fastest growing
programming language
Python Programming has become one of the
fastest growing programming languages in
the world and is a primary language for
many applications
its popularity has grown both in India
as well as in the U.S
in January 2021 python was in the third
position in the top index in January
2022 which is this year python has
become number one in the top index of
popular programming languages
the ratings are based on the number of
skilled Engineers worldwide courses and
third party vendors
popular search engines such as Google
Bing Yahoo Wikipedia Amazon YouTube and
Baidu are used to calculate the ratings
coming to our
third reason that is python is big
enough friendly
the main reason why python is an
excellent choice for beginners is its
simplicity
python supports English syntax and is
designed to be concise and easy to read
all of which make it more accessible to
first-time coders
it is an interpreted programming
language this means that you can run
each line of code once you have finished
writing it allowing you to immediately
check it and make adjustments if needed
the fourth reason we have is python
libraries and Frameworks
python provides numerous libraries and
Frameworks that cater to every need of
the user and its clients
it has numpy and pandas for numerical
competition and data manipulation sci-fi
for scientific computation matplotlib
and c bond for data visualization scikit
loan for machine learning stats model
for statistical analysis and much more
python also supports Frameworks such as
flask and xangu for web applications
you can also do cross-platform and cross
browser testing with Frameworks like Pi
test and robot
now moving ahead
the fifth reason we have is python for
data visualization
python is a great programming language
for data analysis and data visualization
so it supports libraries such as
matplotlab c-bond bokeh and plotly for
creating interesting visualizations
you can make sense of complex data sets
and visualize your findings through
various representation options like bar
graph pie charts graphical plots
geographical maps and much more
now moving ahead
the sixth reason we have is extensive
online documentation
python has been adapted to the latest
advancements with developers
continuously releasing new and improved
versions
Python language is very organized and
its libraries have coexisting
documentation letting you jump start
straight into programming
you will also find example codes where
you can see the functions implemented So
reading the documentation is a good way
to improve your knowledge about python
moving on to the seventh reason why you
should learn python in 2022 we have
python is great for scripting
python is also used to write scripts to
do automated tasks such as backups and
Cleanup in servers
in Python you don't have to compile the
code in order to interpret it you can
directly write code in the script and
execute it the machine reads interprets
and runs the required tests and also
performs error check-in
now coming to the eighth reason we have
python for cyber security
python has been dominating the cyber
security industry and has been around
for a long time now
it can help to automate tasks across the
Cyber attack life cycle for both cyber
attackers and Defenders
you can develop custom Python scripts to
automate cyber security tasks with
libraries such as nmap Yara scapee and
twisted python is used heavily in
malware analysis host discovery
sending and decoding of packets
accessing servers and network scanning
now moving on to our ninth reason we
have python Community Support
you always need a community to learn new
technology and friends are your best
asset when it comes to learning a
programming language
the Python programming language has a
global Community with millions of
software developers who interact online
and offline in thousands of virtual and
physical locations
in case of any coding related issues you
can always seek help from the python
community
as shown on the screen python has a robo
stand supportive online community with
over 1.5 million GitHub repository
communities such as stack Overflow also
bring several python experts together to
help newbies
now moving on to the
10th reason in our list we have python
jobs in high demand
as python is getting more popular along
with an increase in an active community
and its functions the demand for python
professionals is also increasing python
jobs are increasingly growing in every
business sector and provide High
salaries python developers is one of the
highest paid jobs in the United States
the average salary of a python developer
in the U.S is over ninety six thousand
dollars
today we're going to cover python one of
today's highly utilized programming
languages for its many diverse uses I'll
be working in pie charm pycharm is put
out by jetbrains that's
www.jetbrains.com pycharm slash where
you can download it the benefits of
using pycharm is it creates an in
Virtual environment so you can change
what version of python you're using you
can make all kinds of alterations in
there for this tutorial any python IDE
will work but will be in the pycharm
setup it is a really good setup to use
on there and again you can download it
here from the jetbrains website so in
the pi charm environment and if you're
not using this you'll need to follow
whatever IDE setup you have for doing a
new project we've created a new project
we're going to create a new scratch file
this scratch file we can call whatever
it is we want it's going to be a python
file since we're working in Python it'll
call it scratch 3 python we can also
rename this you can see I have a number
of other scratch files delete them
remove them whatever you need to do so
we're going to be working on our our
python in this IDE and again whatever
IDE you use will work just fine for this
Python tutorial and we're going to start
with variables in Python the most
fundamental building block you need
variables are entities of program that
hold a value x equals 100 the box is
holding a variable would be the name
given to the box and if you studied
basic algebra x equals three x equals
100 it goes a little bit beyond just
equaling numbers because we can also do
words but we're going to look at just
variables and let's go ahead and pull
that up in our user interface and see
what that programming looks like in the
script language so in Python we can do
something like print this is a simple
print statement so whatever we put in
here is printed back out so we're going
to put in here meet Jane and let's also
have it print Jane works as a software
engineer and then let's also do one more
print line just so you can see we're
looking at print and then we have Eli's
is Jane's manager and in here you can
run it a number of ways we'll go
underneath run and here's our alt shift
F10 also does this and it asks me what
do I want to run I want to run the
scratch 3 because I have multiple
scratch files in there and we'll click
on there and it'll run it if you're on
like a different ID you might pop up
with the black box it prints it out and
you can see here it says meet Jane Jane
works as a software engineer Elise is
Jane's manager I always take that space
out so it just looks nicer so we have
that and it's kind of nice if you just
want to print something out and there
certainly is a lot of times when you
want to print the title of something you
might have your HTML code on the server
and you print it out and that's what
people actually see if they go to the
python and it accesses that python code
it'll print out the HTML and it'll just
be text printing it out now this is all
great let's go ahead and put a comment
in here just so we can track what's
going on a comment uses the hashtag so
this just tells it this isn't code this
is just a comment for our notes while
we're programming and this over a little
bit so you have a better space on here
instead of typing pain every time we can
also store it as a variable so let's go
ahead and store that and we'll call it
name equals Jane so now we have the
variable name and now we can do
something like this we can go print
there's our brackets we want meet and
I'm just going to do a simple comma
everything that's separated between
commas they'll print out in a row so we
have meet and then we'll just do the
name and if I run this you'll see meet
Jane Jane works as a software engineer
Elise is Jane's manager and then it just
says meet Jane because we've replaced
the name with Jane and we'll take this
off the top I'm just going to delete
that out of there so we can move on to
this next setup with the variables and
we can also go print this is kind of a
cool system because I can now do string
we can hold the space for a string works
as a software engineer and then if
you're going to put a placeholder in
there it has to know what the
placeholder stands for and this is one
of the formatting options when you print
something out so do something simple
like this we have a placeholder for a
string works as a software engineer so
placeholders supposed to be inside the
brackets when we hit run you'll see meet
Jane and then he also prints Jane works
as a software engineer you can see that
right down here in the output the
terminal output from the run so instead
of having to type Jane over and over
again we can now put a placeholder in
there and the same thing with the last
setup print Elise is and there's our
placeholder the percentage sign and the
S and then we have name afterward let's
go ahead and run that and you can see
here that we've now printed out the the
first one meet Jane and notice that this
puts more a little bit more it has one
space in here but you don't really
control the spacing on here so when we
do a formatting and we insert it as part
of the format you can see right here we
put the name it now has a nice format
like I couldn't do this with a comma but
I can certainly do this down here with
the apostrophe s for elise's Jane's
manager and then we can also instead of
having Jane up here maybe Jane got fired
and may got hired well let's just say
there's a second employee named May so
now we have the name May in here and I
can run this and you'll see it now
prints meet may may works at software
engineer elise's May's manager so we've
just swapped May in for Jane and then
one other important feature of python
variables is we could have name two also
equal to may keep the same name on there
and let's go ahead and print we'll do ID
of name and then I also want to print
the ID of name two and what the ID does
is the ID goes in there and says hey
where is this name coming from let's go
ahead and run that and you'll see it
actually gives us a memory address and
so one of the things you find out about
python is to help save memory let me
just Swap this out here in Python
variables with the same value hold the
same memory base so we have name equals
to May name two equals may we print the
idea of name and name two and you'll see
that they occupy the same memory space
now if we happen to swap one of these
out we'll do Jane again we run it they
now have two different memory spaces so
even though I make changes in here this
is one of the ways that Python's really
good about saving memory in the computer
and the last thing we want to note here
which leads us into the next piece of
programming is that this is a string up
here name equals Jane so we're talking
about different data we really have to
also talk about different data types and
very specifically we're going to look at
numerical data so we talk about numeric
data talking numbers the various types
of numeric data are integer float and
complex there are an advanced
programming additional numerical data
types which have to do how it stores the
data but these three are the ones you
need to know about to get started in
your scripting language and the most
commonly used and so an integer is just
simply that it's an number equals five
and then if I print and you can always
find out what type of variable you have
if you do a type on it so we're going to
print type number and so if I run this
it comes out and it says class integer
down here so this is an integer number
and you can also do negative on these so
if I run -5 it's still a class integer
whether it's plus or minus and the most
the second most commonly used number is
your float and it's just like it sounds
we have let's do a number equals 5.6 and
if you notice I used the same variable
name num on there so I can actually take
this and I can just copy this and at
some point we'll talk about ways of not
having to recopy your code so you can
create definitions but let's go and take
a look at this so we have our float our
number now equals 5.6 and if we print
the number type we'll see that it is
first an integer and then a float value
and let's do this just to number just to
remember we're looking at number and
then finally complex so if we have a
complex number we'll go ahead I'm going
to keep number number in there usually
you don't leave it as number because
then it confuses the code later on but
just for this particular piece of code
we're going to keep it number and I'm
going to do 5 plus 6 J and let's go
ahead and print that out so we can see
what these look like and here's our
number comma type number and let's run
this and let's see we got here we have a
5 which is an integer 5.6 which is a
float so it has a decimal place there
that's what the float stands for so your
5.6 5.7 5.8 and then we have 5 plus 6j
is a complex number and if you remember
from math complex numbers based off of I
squared equals minus 1 or the square
root of -1 is that imaginary number now
I'll be honest with you I don't use
imaginary numbers much unless something
comes up where I take a square root of a
minus one and then I end up with a
return of a complex number so it's
important to know it's there and know
what it is when it comes up and with
anything you do have to be pay attention
when you do conversion so we can convert
these things back and forth and let's go
ahead and put a little note here
versions and let's start by oh let's
just do here's our print and we'll go
ahead and do our number comma type back
to what we were doing before so we know
what the type it is and type number so
that's just from before on there and
let's say we want to convert it from a
regular number to a float and we can
simply do something that looks like this
and let's go ahead and pull ways here's
our number but I want to convert it so
I'm going to convert it to float and
then if we do that over here 2 and I go
float that in Brackets so we're going to
print this out and if I run this we now
have 5 as a class integer 5.0 is a float
so I've converted it to a float here and
we can also convert this to a complex
just like we did here with float I can
simply put in complex and we'll do that
over here also complex number and if I
run this we now have 5 plus OJ so this
is a complex number there's no actual
negative imaginary numbers is part of it
so you're going to get
ruin the J part so this is one way to
convert it and you convert it this way
we'd also convert it back so you can
convert to between any of these and
let's take our number and let's make it
worth 5.6 so if you remember correctly
this is now a float and if we wanted to
take that float value print integer of
our number and then of course type
integer of our number and if we run this
we started up here with 5.6 so by
default it automatically makes it a
float value and here we have it we
converted a float to a float so it's not
going to really do anything and then we
convert it to an integer and look what
happens as an integer as an integer it
just truncates the six write off so you
got to be very careful when you're going
the wrong direction on this so if you're
going from float to integer you're going
to lose a decimal value if you're going
from integer to flow which is very
common thing to do especially with data
science you don't lose anything you just
gain the decimal place so if I when we
did it earlier we had five became 5.0
and then you can see where it becomes a
complex number and we can do that just
about any Direction you want with the
conversion python is really nice that it
lets you do that but you do have to be
careful that you don't lose information
that you need so we've looked at
variables we've looked at numerical
variables and how they differ the next
question is what happens if you have a
lot of data you really can't just number
one number two number three that's
really not going to work in programming
so three of our basic lists is lists in
Python a list is a collection of data
and it can hold values of multiple data
types so you can see here we've set a
value of variable X and we'll set it
equal to 189 a a0b and it can store that
in there there's also the Tuple so we
have list Tuple and set the Tuple almost
has the same format as the list but
instead we put the curved brackets
around it and what this means is a tuple
is an immutable collection of
heterogeneous data big mouthful there
what it means is once I set the Tuple I
can't go in there and change one piece
of it far as the Tuple is concerned
that's one variable where a list is a
list of sub variables 189 a a0b a tuple
you can't change anything in here now
you can access it the same way you do a
list but you can't make any changes on
this Tuple other than completely
overwriting it and then finally there's
a set we put brackets around it now
there's some other more complex data
sets that go with this that go above our
data type collections of data but these
are the three Basics and the set is an
unordered collection of unique
heterogeneous data so it's Unique so if
you put in 153 hey six Python and I try
to add six in here you'll only store one
value of six since these are all unique
in here so let's jump into our IDE and
let's create a list remember it uses
square brackets that's how we denote
that this is going to be a list let's
just throw some numbers in there four
five seven five so now I have a list and
we can do a simple thing like print the
list and if we run this we'll see it
come out down here as one four five two
seven five and one of the cool things
about lists is that these are indexes
and this is kind of important to
understand what the index means so we'll
go ahead and print list and it always
starts with zero so if I run this and I
print 0 it's going to print the one
because that's in the zero place and if
we print here's our list we print a one
on there and we run that we have Fork
that's in the one place so zero one two
three four five so there's zero through
five and this is interesting because if
we print let me go back up here to the
top I'm just going to print Lin which
stands for length of list so this is
going to return the length of the list
and I'm going to run this and you'll see
it says there's six things in there but
it starts at zero so we reference them
as 0 through 5. now if you're new to
this that can be confusing especially
when you're jumping back and forth in
your code so always remember this is
point zero through five it's not one
through six it's zero through five but
there's six entities in the list that's
the length of the list and we showed you
here where you can access your zero
index your one index you can also access
it from the right hand side by simply
adding a negative number in there so if
I add a negative 1 and I run this helps
if I actually put the list in front of
it there we go run you'll see that it
points to the last one in the list so
negative one is the five this again a
little confusing you can't do a negative
zero so negative 1 going back backwards
it starts at one and if I change the
negative one say to two you'll see it'll
go to the seven prints the 7 out there
so we can do some very basic indexing
and look at any one of these entities in
the list and then get the length of the
list so we know how long our list is now
really common is not just to want one
entity instead of wanting just one into
T in here let me just get rid of some of
the notes here so that we can see what
this looks like I might want to access
the first four values so I can do print
list 0 4. and your first thought may be
that we count this zero one two three
four which would be five entities but we
don't count the four so this is zero to
three so whenever you see this axis from
left to right positive side it's going
to give us the first four element but it
starts with zero zero one two three
which is our one four five two and since
we're starting from the beginning you
can always just leave the zero out and
we can do something like this this gives
us the same answer whether you put the 0
in or leave the zero out it automates
assumes you're starting from the
beginning of the list likewise we can
start from position two and go forward
and if you notice here we get five two
seven five position two if you look at
this we have 0 1 2 2 points to the five
position so if you're going from left to
right you just say hey I want position
two and you get everything to the end
and we could also put a second number in
here like four that's just two three you
get two values remember it doesn't
include the four on here it does include
the two just like you can do indexes
with negative numbers I can now do minus
four so this means that I'm starting
with zero I can leave it out so the
python ways to leave it out you don't
need all that extra script and it goes
up to a negative four well where is
negative four here's one two three four
so this should go up to this location
but not include it and sure enough we
get one four so it goes up to negative
four remember when you're reading it
this way from left to right you don't
include the minus four you include the
first one but not a second one and you
can also put the negative over on the
other side and go minus 4 and if we run
this one now we get
5275 so we have one two three four and
remember it's on the left hand side so
we include it so we have five two seven
five coming out in the bottom and the
last really fun trick you can do let me
just take the minus four out is I'm
going to add a second colon here and a 2
and I'm going to run this and it should
print out every other one so goes one it
skips one so it counts at one two one
two and we get the one five and seven
coming out and you can see that down
here and you can add in any of your
other numbers in here so we can start at
one instead of at zero and now you get
four two five so again we're skipping
every other one but now we're starting
with the digit in the index number one
place last thing to note is that these
are all integers if I put a 1.0 in and I
run it it's going to give me an error it
says I can't slice a float value even
though it knows what I one is
is and that's important to know if
you're slicing your data into thirds I
don't know how many times I forget to do
that to change it convert it back to an
integer and it'll say I can't slice
3.6666 or whatever it is so remember to
convert that into integers so another
thing to remember about lists that can
be mixed so I can come in here and
instead of it being all in this case we
had all integers I could easily put
python in here and instead of seven
we'll do 7.4 comma 5. and if I print
this out let me just take that out of
here and by the way is this this
functionality of the index Works
identical no matter what's in your list
but we come in here and you'll see I
have one for python 2 7.45 and lists are
mutable so just like I did just like I
referenced um the index I can say list
of let's do one which is going to be the
fourth place equals let's do hello and
if I print my list now you'll see down
below where it comes out goes from 1 4
python to 7.45 to 1 hello python to
seven point before 5. and because these
are mutable with the lists we can also
do something like list dot append and we
can append simply learn and now if I
print my list out and I run this you'll
see that I've added simply learn to the
end of the list and if I do a link to
the list it's now gone from six to seven
oh let's just do that real quick print
length of list so now it's seven so
we've added one more unit to the lists
they're very mutable very flexible use
of setting up lists and then we can also
take this list let's do a new one we'll
call it nested we can create nested
lists what that means is that here's my
brackets to Define that it's a list and
I can fill this with whatever objects I
can think of these can be anything but
we'll stick to numbers I'll do one two
and then I'm going to also create a
nested list and we'll create two comma
three comma four so now I have a list
within a list so now we have a nested
list and if we print this this is print
our nested list out you'll see down
below it prints it out just like I typed
it one two comma two three fours and
nested inside the nested list and then
another option to append is we can also
do nested extent and we could go in here
and let's let's create my nested Loop so
I'm adding a nested Loop to a nested
Loop this is kind of interesting because
you'll see here I have a sub list
attached to the list and I'm going to
take the nested extend I'm going to
extend this on here and if I run this if
I take this and run this let me make
sure I print the nested again you can
see how it's been transformed and I got
one two two three four and it's added
the seven eight nine on there now I was
just adding one nested list on here I'd
probably just a pin brackets around
seven eight nine but if you were adding
multiple nested lists on here you might
do something you want to use the extend
on here so we have one two sub list two
three four sub list 789 and sub list
five six seventh I've added two
different
nested lists onto this so we've looked
at lists we've covered indexing of lists
we've covered appending or extending and
sub lists let's go ahead and talk about
tuples and tuples are really important I
am amazed when I first heard about them
I was like why why have a list and why
have a tuple so the Tuple is your curved
brackets around in this case we're going
to do one two three and the most
important thing to know about the Tuple
is I can't change it I can't go in there
and change the one to a zero now I can
change Tuple and have it equal something
else but I can't change the pieces of
the two bolt and that's what's so
important about the Tuple on this and
you'll see when I print it it also
prints it with the curved brackets so
that lets me know that this is immutable
I cannot change the Tuple now we can
access the Tuple just like you did the
list I can print Tuple position one and
if I run that it's going to print two
because remember we start with 0 1 I can
do just the same way we did the indexing
I can do up to one which would print
just the 1 because 0 and it doesn't
include the one and there's our Tuple
comes out with one comma so a little
different output you'll see this kind of
notation when you're accessing slices of
a tuple and you know all the different
functionality for indexing is the same
we can even do it in reverse we didn't
show you that on the list but this works
just as well on the list instead of the
two for skipping we can do a minus one
and that just goes in reverse so now I
have a tuple of three two one so I talk
about it not being able to be changed if
we take and just get rid of the print
for a second and let's print let's do
this Tuple of one is now going to equal
seven if I run this it's going to throw
an error because we cannot change the
pieces of the Tuple I can reassign
something else to TPL my variable but I
can't change it it's immutable and one
of the very common uses of a tuple is to
use it as a key for something else now
we're not going to cover Keys and codes
in this tutorial but imagine if you have
an ad address to a house and the house
is 123 Main Street and someone can just
change that address then your house just
kind of jumps all over the place so you
want that address to be unchangeable
immutable and this is like a key code so
it's probably a key to some data so it's
a reference usually in some point or
some kind of data that can does needs to
be set and unchanged when you set it for
a tuple and we can do there's some other
cool things we can do with a tuple now
let's just take this one we can do
something you can there's what they call
packing and unpacking tuples so just
like we assigned the Tuple one two three
I can also do Tuple equals we'll do five
six eight just because and if I print
Tuple and we run that it's still going
to create a tuple out of it and so we're
saying hey this Tuple is equal to these
three values whatever they are and now
this variable is equal to these three
values and automatically converts it
into a tuple if you do it that way and
we can unpack our Tuple I can do a comma
B comma C equals Tuple and if we print a
comma B comma C run that you'll see we
get our five six eight right back so we
can unpack it and pack it you see this a
lot when you're doing definitions in
programming where you're packing and
unpacking the data you'll get to the
point when you're doing scripting you
don't really even notice or think about
it until you're like oh yeah that is a
tuple it reminds you on that one but it
does come up a lot and then another
strange thing I can do is I can do a
star list now in this list is a variable
and a is also our letter A just from
right above and I'm going to set that
equal to a tuple and let's print that
out let's print a comma list and if I
run this you'll see that I get 5 which
is our a and then it creates a list out
of the remainder so once I've pulled a
out of the first part I now have list in
there and I could have done a comma B
comma C equals two bolts so this is
straight from up above where we have a b
c equals Tuple a comma star list just
splits them up into two parts the first
part it refers to is just the value you
and the second part it puts into a list
square brackets so you can see how
that's set up in there and how you can
pull that information and manipulate it
and then well finally we'll look at set
and you can create a set yes equals and
usually you denote it with the squiggly
brackets and one two three three four
five and if you look at this if you
remember the set should not repeat any
values so if I print set and I run this
I now get one three four five and I'll
get rid of all my duplicate threes so I
can only have unique values in a set and
if we're looking at this this is also a
subgroup of a tuple so that means that
if I do s of one and I try to change one
of the members in there equals one so
I'm trying to change position one which
is a three to a one and I run that
that's going to give me an error I can't
change it I can't append to it so it's
just like a tuple I can't change these
values in the set what I can do is I can
take a list and let's just let's just
change this we'll go list equals we'll
change these to square brackets so now I
have my standard list and we'll do a
list down here print our list and then
I'm going to print and we'll use the
keyword set and we're going to change
this from a list to a set and then I'll
go ahead and print that out and if I run
this you'll see that my list has all the
values but the second I convert it to a
set which is a special kind of Tuple
that doesn't let you repeat values
you'll see that it gets rid of all my
duplicates so now I have one three four
five in there in my set so now we've
looked at a lot of different ways to
store our data in different variables we
have our list variable we had our basic
variables we had our Tuple we showed you
how to do a set let's start doing
something with this information we'll
start with arithmetic operators the most
basic ones plus minus divide now let's
just take a look and see what that looks
like and we'll need some variables to
play with so we can look through the
basics and if you remember we did a
comma b equals or b equals a comma B and
all that we can actually do eight comma
b equals 10 comma 5. that's nothing more
than what we already did just a little
different formatting what I'm saying is
the a equals the 10 the b equals the
is all that is and I could write that
out a equals 10 b equals 5 just as
easily and our basic arithmetic
operators you're going to see is we have
a plus b and we'll do this Ctrl copy put
a bracket around it so we have our a
plus b set up on here and if we run this
we should get what we expect a plus b 10
plus 5 equals 15. and we can do that all
kinds of different ways fact if we look
at all the basic operators let me just
do it uh now let's keep it this way we
can take this we have instead of a plus
b we'll do a minus B and let me grab
that and put that over here and let me
just go down this and do them all in one
shot there we go paste them right in
there and mostly used to be pretty
familiar the first four are your a plus
b a minus B A times b a divided by B and
so we look at that we get a plus b is 15
a minus B is five ten minus five is five
multiply and we get 58 divided by B
gives us 2.0 row and now we hear kind of
an unusual one we have a double slash B2
what this is saying is that if there's a
remainder let's just convert it to an
integer remember I was telling you
earlier I sometimes have to slice my
data so into thirds instead of going
length divided by 3 I could do length
slash slash over three and that gives me
an integer and it just tells me Hey
where's my first third of data in
where's that at but if you do that you
also want to know what the remainder is
so that's what the Amber sign is is a or
percentage sign that's what the
percentage sign is a percentage sign b
equals zero and then finally you can
square it and whoops I forgot to put
that as a two data science you tend to
do a lot of squaring you do like the
square means error so it's very common
to see something to the power of two and
so you'll see that a times times 2 gives
you U squared value this is actually b b
squared is 25 5 times 5 is 25. so these
are your basic arithmetic operators
there's really with the first four
there's no surprises you just have a
surprise here when you do a double slash
because it Returns the integer and just
drops the decimal when you have the
percentage sign it turn gives you just
the return value so 5.5 comes back as
0.5 and then you have your the double
star is your squared so b double star 2
is squaring your value and we can take
any of these functions and assign them
so I could do res as my variable equals
a plus b and then res now becomes equal
to a plus b which should be 15 when I
run it and sure enough there's my 15. so
now I can take A and B and they might
come in from all kinds of different
areas and set another variable that goes
out to where whoever needs it returns it
to the other part of the program is res
and again this is true whether we do a
plus b a times b a divided by B any of
those basic functions is going to give
us the set the variable res to that now
we can also do what they call shorthand
for a lot of this so we'll do counts the
most common one you do a count equals
zero because you want to know it runs a
process adds one to it runs a process as
run to it so we could do count equals
count plus one and then if I print count
you'll see right here we get count
equals count plus one I get one zero
plus one is one I can also do we'll just
do it up here count equals but instead
of putting the equals argument but plus
equals one and this means I take count
and I might as well put the count here
and the plus sign and we can run that
and you'll see it now equals two so I
get count equals count plus one count
plus equals one is the same thing so
I've added another one to it and now I
have two and we can actually do this
with anything any of the main I could do
count times equals to itself times one
and of course one times one is one so
we'll do something a little bit more
exciting like 1 times 3 and I get three
and we could do this instead of with
count let's do a divide equals two and
that's print
if we run that we get five so I've taken
a which is 10 I've divided it by 2 a
divided by 2 is 10. and again any of
these operators that we just looked at I
can now do down here now there's the
integer version we can do the percentage
sign run that has a zero remainder so
that's what comes up with it maybe
remember I was doing thirds if we do
thirds we can see I get a remainder of
one if I do divide a divided by three
there's my 3.3333 very common but then I
can also do the double divide and I get
just my 3 out of there so a whatever
your arithmetic operator goes here
equals 3 is the same as a equals a
whatever operator you put there in the
three so we had our basic arithmetic
operators uh we want to look at
relationship or relational operators and
whenever you think of relationship think
true false is this true or is it false
and again we can do our print we'll go a
comma B just so we have it down here
take this at it take my palette a little
little bit there and so we have our 10 5
and then we can do a print a is greater
than b and if you're listening closely I
said think true false is a greater than
b is 10 greater than 5 and if we run
that we get true and if you remember we
did with arithmetic and you wonder where
I'm going with this you'll see that we
have all of our basic operators we have
a is greater than b a is less than b a
is greater than or equal to B A is
greater than or is less than or equal to
B A equals B notice this double equal
sign a little different there and then
we have an asterisk on the bottom so
let's go ahead and run this and you can
see down here is a greater than b true
is a less than b that's false is a
greater than or equal to B it's still
going to be true is a less than or equal
to B still going to be false and then a
double equal sign well because the equal
sign is used in Python to set variables
and to set values whenever you do a
logic where you want to know if it's
equal you have to use the double equal
sign that's very important and of course
is a equal to B the answer is false
remember double equal sign and then if
you're going to have an equals you
should have a not equals so here's our
not which is the exclamation point and
you can see that a is not equal to b
equals true so as we go through here we
have our logical our basic relational
operators which are logic gates on here
and we can take this up a notch to do
this let me just go ahead and create a
little bit of different data here and in
this case I'm going to create an A1 B1
C1 equal to 10 20 30. and of course if
we print those out as you guessed it
that should be just those values
individually let me take this clear my
palette a little bit and run that and
you can see we get 10 20 30 down here
and if we pop up this is where it kind
of gets interesting is we're going to
print we're going to use the same
operators we were just using but we're
going to do uh C1 greater than A1 and
we're going to add an extra logic in
here and C1
is greater than B1 so I'm asking here's
C1 equals 30 is it greater than 10 and N
is a greater than 20. and if I run that
we get true because that you know it is
C1 is greater than A1 C1 is greater than
B1 now what happens if we had A1 is
greater than B1 and C1 is greater than
B1 well if we run this we're going to
end up with false because A1 is not
greater than B1 but we can instead of n
we can do or so if I run this we'll now
get true because C1 is still greater
than B1 so there's our or value and you
can stack these I could do A1 greater
than B1 or C1 B1 you could end up with a
very lengthy logic statement at some
point you got to avoid that you have to
find another means to do that but those
are two basic ones is and and or and
then finally not so I can take any of
these logic gates and I can change them
from A1 is greater than B1 to not a
one's not greater than B1 so is A1
greater than B1 no this would return
false but then we just reverse it with
the knot and it comes out as true so
let's go ahead and clear this and we're
going to look at a very complicated I
don't know if it's really complicated
we're going to touch upon what easily
becomes a complicated subject which is
bitwise operators in Python so you can
imagine let's just go back to what is it
we had our AB ten and five so let's go
back there and pull that back in here so
we're going to have our two variables a
b 10 and 5 and we're going to look at
bitwise operators to understand the
bitwise operator let's go ahead and
print binary of a go ahead and do the
binary of B and we're not going to dig
too deep into this I just want you to be
aware of it for more advanced
programming and you'll see it comes out
here here's the bit value which is your
one zero one zero and this would be all
zeros up until there and that's what the
zero B means it's binary and everything
else on this side is zero and this is
the same thing 5 is represented by 101
10 is represented by 10 and 10 in binary
when you switch it over so we look at
this binary switches we're going to do
that we can go let's do print A and B so
if we run this we end up with zero and
that's kind of interesting because how
the heck do they get 0 out of that you
know this is 10 10 and 101 well if you
line this up this one on the right hand
side lines up with the zero so guess
what that's zero we take this zero we
line it up with this zero and guess what
we get we get zero there's no and it's
not the same value and we have one and
zero so we are doing a if this equals
this if this equals this and if this
equals this we get print a which prints
out was a printout zero because none of
them match and we can do something like
print a and you use the up down bar and
unless you do a lot of work with this
you almost always have to look it up if
you're dealing with binary number or
with shifts and things like that of
where these decimal places are and so
we're going to do a or b for we run that
we get 15 and if we print let's just
print this in binary so you can see what
that looks like so if we print A or B in
binary let's run that so remember up
here we got 0 I forgot to convert print
print let's try that again let's print
this in binary and if we print this in
binary you'll see now that it's an or so
we have 1 or 1 equals one zero one zero
or one equals one one or zero equals one
it gets kind of confusing there but you
can see where if either one has a one in
its place or a it then comes out as one
and so we get one one one one and it
does turn out that when you print this
out it came out as 15. so if you do a
binary or statement on these two numbers
you get 15 on there and we can do this
we can continue this down there are
exclusive so we can do print and we'll
do this instead of a or b we'll do an
exclusive which is your little tilde we
can run that and it's going to return
the same thing because this is
exclusively one so if this had been one
one one one and this had been one zero
one zero we would have seen the one zero
one zero come through on the exclusive
where the or returns all ones and if you
have exclusive you can also have one's
complement so this would be like
negating your number so we can do uh
we'll just do this uh binary and this is
the other squiggly of a and we run that
and we'll see that this googly comes out
as 1011 so it reverses it it's a little
different on this because we are looking
at a ones complement on there so it
changes your logic thinking on there
unless you do a lot of work with it can
really tie your brain and it's kind of
fun to figure out if you play with it
and then finally we have a couple more
cool things you can do this this we can
do print we can do what they call a
shift and I'm going to put this in
binary because it's really hard to make
sense of it if you're not doing binary
and we can do shift two this shifts it
to the left so you can see right here
we've added two zeros on the right hand
side to our a and we have the same
number and then shifted at all to the
left and we can also shift it the other
way shift it this way and we can run
that and now we just shift it off and
these two just get bumped off and we end
up with the last two digits the one zero
because we're shifting everything to to
the right oops I'm sorry we dropped the
one zero pin did it backwards since
we're shifting it to the right we lose
this one zero and we end up with just
this first one zero and this is when you
get into like a huge array of trues
false yes no and you need to compare
them and you can do all kinds of cool
things in here again it's a very
Advanced logic when you're doing bitwise
operators but it's important to know
they're there and understand what they
are so when it does come up you know
where to look for them and finally
talking about logic we'll need to go
ahead and look at membership operators
very useful thing to have let's just do
a list equals I will do one two back
there one two three four five so we have
our basic list and the question is uh
let's assign a variable x x equals two
and so let's go print X in list and what
do you think that's going to print is x
in the list is 2 in there and the answer
is yes so we get true so it's going to
print true in there and you can remember
we can also add the not in there is X
not in list we run that it equals false
and when we start looking later on here
or shortly at our if else list and while
this you'll see where this comes in
handy to get these true false statements
on here and then we have identity
operator clearer palette identity
operator and this is oh let's do x
equals 10 y equals 10 and let's print X
is y and if we run this we get true
because remember when python points to
the memory it stores the 10 in the same
place and so X is y and if we change
this to y equals 12 it will now give us
a false because they're no longer equal
so and you could also replace this with
X I don't do a lot of X Y is y it does
come up so you need to be aware of it
but it's not usually just do x equals y
false but X is y I change it to 12 so
again false and then you can also go in
here X is not y so is y or is not Y and
it's true it is not y so these are all
the basic functions arithmetic functions
that you find with your python install
but we're going to cover next is what
happens if it's not in there what
happens if you have some more
complicated math equations you need to
run well at that point you got to import
math so the import it's important to
know what the import is if we have an
external module two python so it's not
part of the basic python code you import
that module and math is used so much
that they have it bundled with the
python install but by default it doesn't
load into your IDE into your user face
or or into the program so when you go to
use math you have to run the import on
there and let's just take a look and see
what some of the stuff that math covers
now I did a quick Bing search and it
took me to python this is always nice
because we have the actual version here
which version of python you're in the
documentation Python and then we went to
the math module and in the math module
we have ceiling we have copy the sign
Fabs factorial floor ceiling and floor
kind of interesting this is really from
an external Viewpoint it's rounding up
or rounding down but there's other
things that go on behind the scenes that
we might use this instead and then
there's here's our basic functions and
if you scroll down you can see it just
covers all kinds of different things
like is it finite is it infinite is it a
nan modify f Powers so if we're going to
do an exponential we saw how to square a
value but if you wanted to do something
to the third or the fourth you have to
import the math module to do that and
you can see here we have exponential of
one this is like exponential x minus 1
log X all your log functions are in here
square root there's one that comes up a
lot in data science if you're going to
take the square means of a value for
your error cosine Sines tangents all the
different trigonometric functions all
this is in the math and really we're not
going to cover all the different things
you can do in math because that's its
own domain if you're working with
degrees and radians or hyperbolic
functions there's just a lot in the math
module including mathematical constant e
Dao infinite Nan Pi there's your Pi in
there so all this stuff is in your math
module and when we're in here we can do
something simple like print math Pi if I
run this should give me the value of pi
which it does 3.141 so on any of the
functions in here if you import math you
could import something like this you
could import another option let's say I
wanted just the pi value and we could do
something like this we could also do
from math so it tells it to go to the
math module import pi if we do this we
don't need the math in front of it so
we're just importing the pi and I can
run this and now you can see I have Pi
here same thing and we can do all the
functionality that you saw earlier let's
go back to import math and set up Pi
let's go ahead and do go do a variable
so we could put in x equals 9.5 and then
from here from our math we could do if
you remember from the very top they had
the ceiling which I said was the same as
rounding it up we could do print ceiling
of X and if I run this it should give us
10. so ceiling is actually the nearest
integer that's greater than 9.5 you
could also do again there's a cosine
tangent all of these functionalities are
in your math module let's see what
tangent looks like 0.0753 there you go
and then there's a couple that I see
regularly in the coding one is power so
I could do x equals 9.5 y equals to
stick to 3 and we can do x to the Y or X
cubed and we can see we get 857 and
0.375 I use the power when I'm trying to
figure out how long it's going to take
to run certain programs especially when
you're going through a lot of
permutations you might find yourself
going okay I got three permutations and
each permutation has three different
variations well that's three to the
three so if I run it once through I can
guess that the time is going to run by
doing three to the three and then I can
just program it to guess what my time
output is another one is of course
square root so we could do the square
root of that's another very common one
square root especially in data science
when you're Computing the error we can
do the square root of x so we can do the
square root as q r t of x if I run this
I'll print the square root again you
know data science the square root means
error there's your square root
factorials that's another one of those
things that come up probably not as much
but if we're doing the factorial we'll
do y this time and we run it this is
adding up all the numbers up to three so
this is one plus two plus three and it
equals six again those are just a few of
the different mathematical functions you
can do and you can go over to Python and
see the full slew of them on the website
so so far we've looked at data types
storing data math functions so some
things that you can do with the data
that comes in let's go ahead and cover
another area we're going to go into
input and we'll look this is a very
basic way of inputting data and more
specifically inline input so this is not
your windows interface or frames
interface or Windows X Y interface and
there is interfaces for python whether
you're exporting it into an HTML or some
other format that then feeds the data
back into python there's a lot of
different options there but this
specifically is just inline and what
that means is we need to find a way to
get the data in so we'll do name input
there's our input command and then the
first part is the prompt this is what
it's going to prompt you for it says
enter your name and we'll add a the
scoop I like to call it what backward
slash in this case n this stands for new
line that's what this little these two
symbols next to each other is and the
backward slash is a Escape key so if you
actually need to put a variable in with
a backward slash like I want enter slash
your let's do enter get your name this
will print a backward slash and this
will prompt us for our name if I hit
enter you'll see enter get your name and
when I click down here type in Richard
which is my name and hit enter Then it
continues the code on there and then we
can do something with this we can do
print and we'll do hi comma name and
remember with the print this just simply
prints whatever the first one is comma
the second one comma and so on and so I
can now hit this in here when I go down
here it prompt me for my name enter get
your name maybe it gets kind of a weird
way of putting it hi Richard we'll
change this from get to enter input and
we may continue on down here so we'll go
ahead and do input page I'll do page
equals input enter your age and we'll do
that same backward slash n and this time
instead ahead of printing the age we're
going to enter in a an integer this is
kind of a very important thing to know
when you're doing line inputs if I run
this and we print type of the age let's
just go ahead and go through this enter
Richard and it's going to say hi Richard
enter your age we won't put down my real
age let's say I'm a young 25 it's
actually significantly less than my age
and this is interesting because it takes
the input and it's a string that's what
this class string means so whenever you
do an input like this it comes in as a
string and that's important to know
because if you're trying to add age to
something it's not going to come out
very you get an error so I can do print
age plus five because age is a string
when I come in here and I just do this
real quick I misspelled my work my name
type error must be string not integer so
it's trying to add Phi which is an
integer to a string which it can't do so
that's very important when you're coding
you start getting those kinds of Errors
that's where they're coming from is you
got to make sure your two types match
and one way I mean you can convert it I
don't know if you remember from converge
versions I can simply put integer age
we'll do integer age plus one just so
you can see how it's different and it
will convert it to age or to a number on
here to an integer we enter in our name
we enter in our pretend age and you'll
see that it now is able to add one to
that age because I've converted it to an
integer you gotta be a little careful
with this because you might have
characters in there that aren't integer
in which case it'll give you an error at
that point let's do two more things with
this let's go ahead and print with the
format so we have name and age and let's
say we'll do first formatting and we'll
put in an s in there is second formatted
word years old and if you remember from
the formatting we can now take this and
our Amber sign at the end or a
percentage and then we put the two
variables name and age in here and then
I go ahead and run this and if we run
this we enter click down here if we run
this I can type in my name type in my
pretend age if you said Tuple you've got
that right so you've got to remember
sending it as a tuple that's what the
curve brackets do to it so now we run
this it should give me a nice format on
here so it looks it looks pretty
sometimes that's really important
because people are coming in see this
all the time instead of these nice forms
that come up we used to see it where I
do prompts like this for people coming
in and we'll see that we get an error
down here because d looks for a decimal
we have two strings so we could do
something like this integer age and now
if I run it I shouldn't have any errors
on there I should come in here 25 and
there we go Richard is 25 years old and
so we did a couple things in here we now
have our formatting we now have string
versus decimals what the d stands for
that's pretty much any number and make
sure we give it a number so we have a
setup on there and you would probably
want to double check their input if this
was for a form fill out or something
like that although this usually I use
this for small programs where I'm
testing something out and I got to put a
different input in each time I don't use
them very often but it does come up it
does come up where you might need to
test something out real quick or have a
line input for a very long script you're
running and they just need a simple line
input and one of the last things we can
do on here is we can take this and let's
say instead of enter input name how
about a word and we're going to do on
this word if you remember from before we
had our indexes for our list well a word
of any kind is nothing more than a
string of characters and that string is
stored in a list so I can come in here
and take name and I can say hey I just
want the first four letters of that of
your name maybe that's what it is and
we'll print we'll just keep it name
maybe you're creating a username or
reference I've seen this where they have
passwords and things like that set to
the first four letters I hit enter it's
going to return rich just the first four
letters and that's because this index
works just like it does in a list it's
the same index because it is a list and
before we move on to the next section
one more thing I want to note about
input a equals integer if you remember
correctly we did a conversion where if
you had the number in here three a
character this converts it to an integer
gives you an error if you put a in there
we can also do this as a single line
this is very common in Python to try to
bring stuff together they call it the
python way it just makes it a little
easier to read and so you can see right
here enter a multiple of and we'll do
five in this case this actually converts
it so if I go ahead and put it down here
print a we run this to five we get five
and if I type in the type of a you will
of course see that this of type integer
we'll just go and run this real quick
print five class integer so this is just
a way of combining the conversion with
the input you can put it all in one line
like this take it nice and compact so
what we want to cover next is the if
statements and there's like the if the
else the L if we're also going to start
into the loops we're to cover the while
statement which uses the logic gate in
the loop and then we'll look at the four
or four statement which is just a loop
without logic and of course there's a
couple of odds and ends break and
continue which go with the loops so the
if statement this is where we start
doing something with the data we're
putting in so you'll see here I went
ahead did input enter multiple of five
and maybe we want to know if it is a
multiple of five so if a how can we do
that we can do a divided by five and get
the remainder off of that is not equal
to zero so just a little simple logic
there this returns true false if
remember we covered all that true false
statements so if it's not equal to zero
then it doesn't then if it's equal to
zero it has no remainder so it's
multiple of five if it's not equal to
zero it has a remainder which means that
it is then not a multiple of five and we
can just simply have it print and we'll
just uh we'll do this we'll go a comma
not a multiple of five and if I run this
and I enter in and let's just enter in
three three not a multiple of five and
if we have another piece of code down
here we'll just print this is what
so we might have some more script down
here and if we run that we enter in five
it just goes right down to this is what
happens next and if we go back we put in
4 you'll see that 4 comes up and says 4
is not a multiple of five this is what
happens next and so the if statement
only runs if this is true and it runs
whatever is indented so here's our colon
and here's our indent Python's very big
on the end it's how it tells what piece
of code is different from the next other
languages use different like a semicolon
for Java if you're in HTML you have to
put a block at the beginning at the end
so every different scripting language
has its own setup and this is how python
does it you do an indent right there so
make sure you're very careful where
indents are and then let's go ahead and
just do enter number and if you can do
an if statement we can also have else
statement and the else occurs print a so
if I want to know is this is even or odd
we could do this we could do if a
divided by 2 with the remainder of that
is not equal to zero then this is going
to be what odd so this is an odd number
this is an even number just some basic
logic there and if we run this I can now
come down here enter in four this is 4
is an even number and then this is what
happens next and we can also do this if
I enter in a 5 5 this is an odd number
so just some basic Logics you can see
right here either it is even either it
is odd the remainder is not equal to 2
else whatever is next and the only other
option is it's even now this may be good
if you're just doing a simple you have
two choices we can also do the L if
statement and we put that in before the
else statement L if and then of course
we have our logic here and we'll go
ahead and combine some logic we'll do a
couple things here let's go back up to
this enter a number a copy and enter a
number we'll have a number a b and C so
we'll go ahead and have three different
choices take out this last line and so
the first choice we want to know is is a
the greatest value so we could do a is
greater than b and a is greater than C
so if a is greater than a and a is
greater than b a is the greatest number
so we have this over here and if we have
that we can have L if we can do let's
say b b is greater than a and b is
greater than C we'll go ahead and do
this we'll do a print statement print b
b is the greatest number and if a is not
the greatest number and B is not the
greatest number that leaves one other
option so we'll go down to our else
statement and we'll have else C is the
greatest number and if we run this code
here we enter a number we'll enter a one
two three and it says 3 is the greatest
number and of course if we run this code
again you could do three two one and it
gives me an error because I accidentally
hit a character string there 3 to 32 2.
so if we do this we do three two one we
still get 3 is the greatest number and
finally we could put it right in the
middle and it should still pull it out
we could do one three two and I'll still
come up with three is the greatest
number you can actually go take this as
far as you want so we have just here the
three choices you could have if else if
else there are other ways to do that
when you get more than here but for
basic python this covers most of the
program you're doing with the else and
the else if statement as far as the
logic statements involved in there the
last thing we want to really look at is
a nested if an else statement and we can
do that we'll keep the get rid of some
of this
screen clear our screen here and we can
do is we can go enter let's do enter
your age and we'll call the variable age
up here so we're going to enter the age
and we want to know that oh let's say
this is are you available for a certain
discount maybe it's a bus fare discount
maybe it's you get a discount for a
restaurant or something like that so we
have it here we enter your age and if a
let's do a is greater than 64. so if a
is greater than 64 we put our colon in
there and this is actually age print I
will print you are eligible for senior
citizen discount and maybe we'll be a
little nice we'll make it if you're
greater than 60. how about greater than
or equal to 6 we're really feeling
generous so if your age is greater than
or equal to 60 you get a discount else
we'll print you are not eligible for a
discount we'll go and just run this real
quick and so if you are 66 it'll come up
you are eligible for a discount and if
you put in 40 it will say you are not
eligible for a discount and then we come
along we realize oh hey we have a
discount also for people who are under a
certain age we have our youth discount
so we'll go ahead and come in here and
we'll say oh if your age is less than 18
let's do less than or equal to 19. less
than or equal to 18 print and then of
course we can do see you are eligible
for a minor discount or youth discount
and then we need to come up here if we
want to do this if age is less than 18
since it's nested we'll do an else here
and if I put the else down here a couple
things to notice about this list so we
have our first statement if age is
greater than or equal to 60 you're
eligible for a senior citizen discount
and then we put the else so any logic
whatever happens under this else this is
always going to go if I move this else
back out it'll give me an error because
you can't have two L States and
certainly you could do this as an LF
statement here too so this is kind of
another way of doing an LF statement
sometimes you want to add some so let's
put a note here sometimes you might have
additional script here so before you can
do these two calculations you might have
to do some kind of calculation here
that's why you want to do a nested if
and else statement instead of using the
if LF and else statement and we can see
here if I run this and your age now if
you enter the age nine you are eligible
for a minor discount and of course what
we did before we have somebody who's 56
you are not eligible for any discount
and of course if you're 64 or 60 or
older you get that nice senior citizen
discount and if you were listening to
earlier no I don't qualify for the
senior citizen discount quite yet
although I do look forward to it the
next thing we want to start covering is
our loops and we have the while and for
Loop and so the while loop utilizes your
logic to let it know when did how how
many times to Loop through let's go
ahead and take a look and see what that
script comes out as we can do is let's
go ahead and take a word equals to oh
let's do python since that's what we're
programming in and let's do I equals
zero and let's say while I is less than
or equal to five and since this is we
use that indent just like we did the FL
statement we still need that indent in
the colon there while I is less than or
equal to five let's go ahead and print
word and then we're going to do I if you
remember correctly we're going to
increment it by one we can do a plus
equals one same as I equals I plus one
so I plus equals one and if we run this
we'll come down here and you'll see it
repeats the python in this case five
times and we can even do something like
this let's do a i comma word and let's
run that and you'll see we get 0 1 2 3 4
5. one of the things always to be aware
of is we did I is less than or equal to
five if this was an actual length of the
array you would have array out of bounds
because remember you don't want to
include the length of the rate because
it's 0 to 4. so a lot of times just
remember unless you actually wanted to
print 0 through 5 we can do while I is
less than five print I I Plus or equals
one and then we get our zero one two
three four python now there's other ways
to do a loop like this and I'll show you
in just a minute with the for Loop this
just gives you an idea here's our false
statements and just like we did before
you could have if I is less than 5 or I
is less than 8 which would kind of be
redundant but you could have your or and
and you could have a very lengthy logic
gate right here as long as it returns
true or false so we use the while
because we don't know how many Loops we
want to go through on here in this case
we actually set it to five but maybe
we're building a list and let's just go
ahead and do this we'll do a list we'll
create an empty list let's get an input
and we'll we'll call it C this is enter
one to add elements to list and 0 to
exit Loop the Y
we've created a variable and then an
enter here and the input if you remember
correctly we're not converting this to
an integer so we're going to just go
ahead and keep it as a character and so
we're going to say while C does not
equal and because it's a character we
got to go ahead and put the brackets
around it to let it know it's going to
be a string the string of 0. so long as
this doesn't equal 0 keep doing and then
we're going to do here on our while loop
is we're going to have another input
here and on here we're going to have
input enter an element to add to the
list that's the input integer this one
isn't it we'll just keep it as in three
input I
keep it uniform on there and what we can
do let me just go ahead and copy this up
here so we're going to start adding
elements and the order in which we do
this is always important you never know
how your Loop is going to go I switched
that around because I want to append to
my list C so whatever we enter in on the
first one gets appended to the list and
then we ask for the next one if the next
one is a zero so whatever we type in
there's going to be added to the element
and the order as I was saying is
important because if we put this after
the second input whatever you put in
here is going to ignore and if we put it
before that's going to keep adding it in
until you put 0 in the 0 if you put this
after the zero it will still add the
zero in so you'll end up with a zero at
the end of the list so by putting it
before this input we're going to have
both the first input going in and
whatever input we add in and to get a
view of what this looks like let's go
ahead and print our list when we run
that you'll see it comes up it says
enter 0 to quit and other to add to list
but I can add an A in we can add a 3
T remember I didn't put any bounds on it
making it an image or anything like that
and I'll put the zero and when I put the
zero there it is A3 and T So this while
loop keeps going until it hits something
that says okay we're done and then it
just kicks it out so it finishes the
loop comes back up here says is this
true if it's true we do it again if it's
false then we skip out of the loop and
then it continues on down below where we
printed the list now if you remember
from earlier we had the I plus 1 and we
just looped through to print python out
four times certainly there's better ways
to do that instead of adding all that
math in there and we can do that so word
equals let's do python so we can do that
real just simply by doing a for Loop 4
doesn't require logic we do four we'll
do W in range 10 and let's go ahead and
print W comma word and if I run this
we'll see we have python printed 10
times let me just take that down a notch
since my screen display doesn't show up
as my uh so range three and if you
remember from earlier range does 0 2 3
but doesn't include three I could just
as easily put zero comma three in here
and I'll get the same answer then you
can also add a step on there there's a
lot of controls you can add with range
so we can print W range of three and
that's pretty cool just prints word over
and over and over again but we can also
do with this is we can create a list so
I can create my list there's our square
brackets and we could do one two let's
add hello We'll add a sub list which is
one two three and so we can do on this
is I could do instead of a range I could
do object in list so for object and list
I want to print just the object and if
we run this you'll see down here we have
one two hello and then it printed the
one the sub list the whole sub list in
there one two three because that's one
object in there so it just iterates
through each entity in the list and
prints it right out what we can do now
text is we can kind of combine some of
these so you've seen the for Loop we
have our if statements along with some
different logic gates we can do so we
can do let's do this let's go word
equals input and let's do enter word so
we're going to get a word from you off
of your keyboard let's do count equals
zero and we're just going to count
vowels we're going to use the loop to
count the number of vowels in word so
for I in word remember from before we
can iterate through each object and when
you do a string so if we have if our
word was equal python we have p y t h o
n each one of those is an object in that
list that's an actual list so let me
enter the word that's a list of letters
so this is just going to go through and
look at each one of those letters and
we're going to say hey if I in and we'll
give it an array if it's a e i o u or
capital a capital e capital I capital O
capital u these are seen differently
they're very characters on there we have
our our colon here this lets us know we
need to indent at this point we know
it's a valve so we want to go ahead and
count plus equals one and then we just
want to go down here and say print
number of vowels in oh let's do a little
formatting s is D if we remember we got
to create that little Tuple at the end
with all those different values and so
here is our word and our count so let's
go ahead and run this and for the word
I'll go ahead and enter in count and we
can see the number of vowels in count is
two and sure enough it's got an OU in it
and if we run this again and let's do
counting we can see that there's three
vowels in there o u and I now when we're
talking about loops both the while loop
and the for Loop and this works actually
on any the continuing break will work
any kind of indent so even the if
statement I could add a break part way
through the if statement and it will
kick it out so it's important to know
but we want to know break and continue
and how those work so let's go ahead and
create a little script here so we can
take a look at it and break is just like
you think it is whatever it's doing it
it stops it it breaks the flow so let's
go ahead and do this we're going to do a
range 2 comma the integer of n divided
by 2 plus 1. we're going to look for
prime numbers we're gonna see if we can
figure out how to find a prime number
and so what we have going here is I'm
going to take n which equals 49 and to
help me find the prime number we're
going to go all the way through let's
see in range 2 to n divided by 2. we're
going to add 1 to it now for the first
part we don't really need to add the 1
but I'm going to show you in a minute
that for another piece of code we can
put the one in so I'm just going to
leave that in there and we're going to
just divide by each of those I's so I is
equal to 2 3 4 5 6 all the way up to 25
so it's basically 2 to 25. and we want
to take the the and we want to divide by
that but we want to know if there's a
remainder that's how we can tell if it's
a prime number because if it has no
remainder then we have a prime number so
n divided by I the remainder of it if
that equals 0 then this is not a prime
number so we'll print this is not a
prime number and instead of this is
we'll just go ahead and do oh let's just
do something simple and here's not a
prime number there we go now if we
picked a number like 20 it'll get to 4
and print this is not a prime number
it'll get to 5 this is not a prime
number it will get to 10 this is not a
prime number it's going to print that
three times we don't want it to keep
printing that we want it to stop we want
to say hey we got an answer it's not a
prime number break and if we go ahead
and run this we should get 49 is not a
prime number it's divisible by 7. we do
know that oh the number 11 is a prime
number so if I run this it'll just go
through the code and say okay we're good
this is the kind of thing you might do
if you have an input and you're checking
the input to make sure they're valid
inputs you want to come up and say hey
this is isn't a valid input kick it out
or if it's a valid input go ahead and do
the process on there and if you're going
to have break we also need to look at
continue and how that works and so let's
say instead of looking for a prime
number I want to know all the different
numbers that divide into the number I
want to know what it's divisible by and
so we can do that let's do if it's not
equal to then divided by I is not equal
to zero I want it to continue else what
I want to do is I want to print let's do
our place marker we'll do D is visible
by this is also going to be a number so
we'll do another D for decimal then of
course if you do this part we're going
to have our Tuple on the end and in this
case we want to do our number in is
divisible by our number I so let's take
a look and see what's going on with this
code continue unlike just says Hey here
we have our Loop or it could be a while
statement for statement so here we have
our loot I get to here and it says okay
if this remainder does not equal zero I
don't want to do anything after this I
just want to go back to the top of the
loop and so it skips this line down here
it's like an else statement right here
else do this so this is one way you can
almost put an else statement here
instead so I can run this and it says
press is finished because 11 happens to
be a prime number we'll set it to 20
since I brought up that earlier and
we'll see that 20 is dividable by 2 is
divisible by 4 it's divisible by 5 by
10. it just goes right down the list and
so this gives you an idea of how you can
utilize the continue when you're in one
of these Loops to use that logic to help
you get the script to do what you want
it to do the next topic we want to cover
is going to be some more advanced
modules is you get more and more
advanced in Python you really are
starting to look at all these great
modules that are developed by Third
parties one of the greatest drinks in
Python is you get a module to do almost
anything and two of the modules we want
to look at are arrays and numpy these
are in data science they're so important
for storing information and manipulating
it and the difference between an array
because we have remember we did lists
remember lists from before our list they
equal within the brackets and a lot of
times you'll you might have caught me
once or twice hopefully you didn't but
you probably did well I called a list an
array in Python they're not the same
thing that's very important to note
because a list is a base python list of
objects where the array is a special
module you bring in and you got to be
careful when you're talking about other
programming languages an array is what a
list is in Python so you might hear that
terminology they probably have some
other programming languages and they do
have a lot of similarities so we're
going to do from array import Star so
we're going to import everything we have
from the array setup that's all this
means so from our array we're importing
all the different sub modules in it you
could probably just get by with import
array at this point because I would do a
similar thing but we want to let you
know that there is a difference there
and we do an array we just use the array
man code and then we can create the
array inside the brackets and just like
a list we can do all kinds of things
with this as far as mix and match but
one of the nice things about array I can
also tell it it has to be of a specific
type so in this array here I'm
designating these are all integers sent
to it a list of integers one two three
four five and if we print the type of
the array you should see it come down
here and it says okay class array array
has finished so the class is always
going to be an array on here and this
particular array might designate it as
integers we can also do on our print
just like you have like your regular
array you can access the integers by
their index number so we'll put in two
if we print the array of index two we'll
see that it points to three so it's just
like a list so far so far it has all the
different setups you would as a list on
here and this includes append so I could
actually take this and I could go array
append minus 10 we'll run that just
print out the whole and we'll see now we
have an array of type I one two three
four five minus ten something just a pin
just like we did so in other words all
the functionality you have on your list
you're going to find you have with the
array we'll just go ahead and do a
couple more like that so you can see
what that looks like let's go ahead and
remove three so if I remove the value 3
from here you'll see one two four five
minus 10. if we want to go ahead and
print the sorry I printed the index the
first time we can also do an actual
index minus 10 on the array let's go
ahead and run that and we get four this
is kind of interesting because if I did
this with a list I would get an error by
doing the index minus 10. so we have
minus one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten kind of just kind of
Loops over until it gets to the three
but where arrays are different than
lists and this is so important this is
what makes an array an array we'll take
this back here and just print the array
on here I can do something like this AR
equals AR times three and if I run this
you'll see right here my array has now
jumped and so when I do AR times 3 the
array is now 2 4 5 minus 10 and it
repeats it three times so this is one of
the cool things you can do with an array
on here now at this point if you're
doing a lot of functionality on your
array you'll almost always end up in
numbers python so even though there's a
lot of really cool things especially the
type settings so you can actually have
it all integers really in this
particular module you want numpy which
sits on top of array and probably the
most common form you see it you'll see
import numpy as NP now you could just do
import numpy and wherever you see NP you
use numpy now if you are you'll see when
I run this I get an error because I
opened up a new project in pi charm that
means all my modules that are added in
externally aren't there if you are
working to keep an IDE you might go to
the command line and do a pip install
numpy and that will bring it in if
you're using pip there's a number of
different install packages if you're
using jupyter notebooks under conda or
anaconda it's conda install Condit is
the same thing as pip except that it
brings in all the different sub packages
Pep's the most common one you're a pip
install but we're in Python Pi charm and
so in pie chart we want to go up to
click on that file once we're on file we
want to go down to settings once for
under settings we want to go under our
project and then you'll see project
interpreter this is really cool that
we're actually in here because you can
see underneath here we're using python36
so if I had a rollout in a different
version I could go in here and add those
versions in and switch them around I
just have the one on this particular
machine and I go over here to the plus
sign on the right hand side and I click
on there and then for installing in here
we'll type in numpy and once I have
numpy and see there's different versions
of numpy on here generally you want to
ignore all of those unless you're doing
something special and go right to the
one that's just straight numpy and then
click on install package then pycharm
will take over it will install the numpy
package into this particular environment
this is when the beautiful things about
using pie charm is it keeps this
environment separate from everything
else and then once it's installed we can
now go back close out of here out of
settings and there's our numpy added in
there so now it shows me what I have
installed on here this is such a great
tool because I can see exactly what I'm
using in this environment and now when I
run it you'll see I don't get an error
for not having the module so you got to
make sure the numpy module is installed
and this really is if you're doing data
science one of the bread and butter
tools you need is your numpy setup your
numpy array and we'll go ahead and
create our first numpy array we'll call
it ar1 equals NP dot array so NP for
numpy DOT array is the command oh let's
just do one two two three I guess I'm
being a little boring as far as what I'm
putting in it and then let's go ahead
and just print that and see what that
looks like print this is an array made
with a list there's other ways to make
an array but we're just going to print
our ar1 we put a list in there so we
just doesn't need a list into it and
then we print our ar1 and we see that it
comes out it looks just like a list one
of the catches is there's no commas in
here so if I wanted to go ahead and
let's say take our list and you're going
to say why is this so important there's
no commas in there if you're doing a lot
of debugging and you see this first one
you know you're either in an array or a
list if you see the next one you know
you're in numpy so it's just kind of a
quick flag in the programming script and
debugging for some of the things you can
look for now the numpy array starts to
take a major shift here this is where
this becomes real important as far as
the setup we'll talk about shape and
sizes and matrixes here in just a second
let's go ahead and do this we're going
to create two sub lists so remember that
from before we have list one list two if
I'm going to do that I do need to put
brackets around it this
2D sample and you could look at this as
being one of the common things is x y
coordinate so I might have one two three
for x four five six for y and if we
print that out you can see as it comes
down here printer ar1 it prints it out
no commas but you have your two
different lists on here and we can do
something uh like this we can print
Dimensions equals and then I'm going to
do ar2 dot in Dimensions so if we run
this you'll see it comes out with I have
a print our setup on there and it has
two dimensions and that's pretty easy to
see we have Dimension one which is a one
two three in dimension two which is four
five six likewise there's also size and
shape and so if I do this setup on here
we can see that we can get the size the
dimensions as two the size is six just
how many entities are in there and then
the shape this is I don't know how many
times I look at the shape of these
things because you're putting it through
some kind of format and if your shapes
don't match when you're doing machine
learning and you're doing a fit and a
train you'll get an error and so it's so
important to double check your shape and
make sure it's correct make sure we have
a two by three Matrix in this case and
then finally just like you can do this
with any of you know type command we can
also get the what they call d-type in
numpy so in your number array will see
that the type of elements is an integer
32 so it actually Returns what kind of
elements I have in here and they do they
all look like integers on there let's go
ahead and take a short detour here and
just take a look at the numpy official
side so if we go to the official numpy
site we'll see right off the top a
scipy.org which is the group behind it
it's all open source you can actually go
in here and donate to it and it is so
extensive I'm just going to look at data
types and so data types gets its own Tab
and you can see from here we were what
integer there's so many Specialties you
can do with this and so they cover just
about every data type you can think of
there's our integer 32. so here's our
manager 32 that is the standard that's
usually what it converts to if you're
converting from directly from python
into numpy but you can force it into any
of these other different kind of data
types on here so it has a lot of diverse
use on this obviously we can't cover
everything under numpy there's array
creation input output with numpy
indexing broadcasting byte swapping
structured arrays each one of these is a
significantly large topic it's own class
if you will you can see right here we're
going to do that we'll try to cover just
a couple things so you get a little
flavor of numpy so let's take a look at
we have our numpy stuff going on let's
go ahead and look at filling an array
with zeros this comes up because
sometimes you want zero as your
placeholder and so you begin your
process with filling it with zeros or
ones or other values and you can simply
do NP dot zeros and then this is
important as it needs to know the
dimensions we'll do it two by two and
we'll do a d type equals and there's our
integer so we're going to fill it as
integers on here let's go ahead and take
our Z and if we print this out and run
that you'll see that I get a nice two by
two array filled with zero so maybe I'm
doing plotting I don't know what the
plots are but I need to have it
pre-filled yeah a lot of test data does
this you can create your own data and
make stuff up and do all kinds of things
there once you have it pre-formatted and
if we fill it with zeros we can also do
fill it with almost anything
instead of zeros we'll do a full and
let's do two comma three and then
instead of this is to fill it with let's
do one and let's run this and when I run
this you'll see that I've created a two
by three array all filled with ones and
just like our list and everything else
we can come in here and we can access
the different indexes of our numpy array
in this case we're going to do index one
comma two and when I run that we get six
where does one comma two come from well
remember we count from zero so there's
zero one and we count from zero we get
zero one two and so if we do this
Arrangement one comma two is going to be
the row followed by the column and just
like any of these we can get very
complicated we can do something like
this we'll keep this as one and we could
also do so we'll do one we have our
comma but I want to do after the comma a
colon there then I'm going to put in
another colon and if you remember from
before that is we're going to do a step
and let's do minus one so this should
look a little familiar this is the same
kind of format you got from list and if
I run this we're going to look at the
one so zero one four five six I'm going
to select all of them that's what the
first colon is and then the second one
says hey but I want to go backwards
we're going to step minus one and so
we're going 6 5 4 on here that's why you
get the six five four and we could also
do something like this we could add in 2
1 and if we run that you'll see that I
get 3 2 1 because it doesn't include one
I could do up to two and then we get
three two one six five four so now we
have that the first two in Reverse zero
and one and you can just play with this
different ways to select different
entities in our numpy array and although
we can't dig into all the different
aspects of a numpy array I did want to
bring up one last thing which is
operations on a numpy array this is
pretty cool because I can take this and
here's our numpy array we've created we
can do something like this we can take
big print array three and let's just add
10 to it and this is a little different
than what we've seen before so if I run
this and I add 10 to it and we run it
you'll see it adds 10 to every entity in
the array so I have 11 12 13 14 15 16
and so on I'm just adding 10 on there
and likewise I could do all kinds of
different values like times 10 so
they're just multiplied out by times 10.
there is other functionality like you
can sum it so we can sum all the values
in there you could also select just a
slice of this so you could select oh
let's do the first zero and then sum it
and so we get six one plus two plus
three is six so there's sum there's Min
there's Max the slew of commands just
goes on and on and on there's so much
you can do with the numpy array and some
important things to note there's also
what they call transpose and this comes
in a lot when you're graphing because
you might have a graph that looks at X Y
let's go back to our 2D array and it
wants all of X Y by sure Ray came in as
all the rows so you have one comma four
two comma five three comma six and you
need to transpose it if I run this
you'll see that I've gone from one two
three comma four five six to one four
two five three six tends to be the other
way around there's times when you need
the individual Pairs and of course we
could go back and transpose it going the
other way of course this doesn't work
because when you do this it doesn't do
it in place you have to let it know it's
in place if you're going to do that
because we'd have to do something more
like AR three equals AR transpose take
this T out and now we should get it
where it flips it from the original
values to one four two five three six
and back again so we can move the data
back and forth and transpose that back
and forth quite easily with this so we
touched a little bit upon the basics
understanding of numpy it's a really
powerful tool we need to move on and
look at functions functions are so
important in python they're kind of
programmers bread and butter so let's do
a function just call this a fun and in
our fun I wanted to print simply learn
so what I'm doing is I'm creating a
function that allows me to call this
piece of script whenever I want so
instead of having the loop do this I now
have the function do this and instead of
maybe I have this function where I want
to print simply learn I'm at five
different places in my program instead
of retyping it I can just wrap it all up
in a wrapper function
and we can simply just call this the way
you call it is you just type in the name
fun because that's the name of our
function a little confusing there for
fun simply learn is fun I like that kind
of combination and if we run this you'll
see just simply prints simply learn
because this function executes
whatever's in this indent and you can
see right here is our def lets it know
it's a definition the name of our
function and then a set of brackets
right here now if we want to do
something and you know it's exciting
just be able to print something maybe we
want to add two numbers and let's go
ahead and do a comma B we can now put
these numbers in these brackets and this
function now sees these numbers in here
let me go ahead and print oh this is
print a plus b and I'm going to do come
down here and go add and we'll do five
four comma five we'll run that and if we
run that you see four plus five equals
nine well we might not want to just run
it we might want to actually have a
value come out of it and so instead
we'll do s for summation equals a plus b
and then I want to return this value so
now I can come over here and I can do
we'll just call in for number equals add
4 comma 5. and if we print in you'll see
this whole process now brings it all
together so now I have my function I'm
sending it a comma B it's going to add a
comma B and it's going to return the
results for that and then I get that
under my n so I set this variable equal
to that and I print in and something I
want to point out is that this return s
is a tuple and we'll talk about that
again in just a minute or let's why not
we'll just go ahead and do that now so
we have our summation and then we might
have the difference what's the
difference between a minus B minus B and
I'm going to leave this just as n so you
can see what that looks like but we're
going to return s comma D the difference
sum and difference and if I print it out
you'll see that it returns 9 that's our
s and D is a minus 1 and it's in Tuple
form so as chymodi returns this nice
Tuple we can also instead of doing this
I could do N1 comma N2 and then we could
print in one comma N2 and we did this
earlier we were assigning variables it's
the same thing but instead of assigning
this in one comma N2 equal to 2 whatever
they are nine comma minus one we're
having it return from our function so it
comes right out there and then we can
print the two different values and then
this is kind of an interesting thing we
can come up here and pre-center values
going in and instead of a I'm sending it
four comma five I'm going to say a
equals 1 b equals three let's do this
the other way around let's go five if I
run this and I remember last time we
sent it four five and I got 9 minus 1.
now I'm sending it 4 5 and I still get
the 9 minus one but if I take this out
and I don't send it any values it'll
automatically default to the a equals 5
and b equals three and and then we get
our eight two you know five plus three
is eight five minus three is two so
we've covered a lot so far as far as the
basic definition sending it information
returns it as a tuple one of the tricks
you can do is a star args they call them
args and quarks and we're going to talk
a little bit about what the difference
is between args and quarks they are
designated with the asterisks so this is
args now I don't have to call it ours I
could call it my args that is not
specific to the program and we can just
go ahead and print I always like to do
lowercase for the first letter and then
when I change names uppercase and that's
just kind of a python standardization
for naming your different variables and
if I print my args we can come back down
here and I can do let's just call this
call this AK for args and quarks oh
spill it out args args underscore there
we go and so if I go down here and I go
hey let's uh call my function paste that
down here and we'll in here and I'm
going to put in one two three four it
might be I don't know how many values I
have going in I just know that I have a
bunch of values that are going to come
in and I know what order they're in and
so you can see right here it takes my
args we print out my args and I typed in
one two three four and that's what comes
in and we could do something like this
we could print args of one because maybe
that's a specific setup and it'll print
two one is the twos in the one place
that's our index and if we're doing like
addition we could do something like C
equals my args 0 minus let's do addition
plus my args one and you can guess on
here if we return call it a we can come
down here and do a equals args of quarks
and then if I print our a and I run this
you can see it comes up with three
because one plus two equals three and it
might be that you only do stuff if 3 and
4 exist let's just do it this way well
this is uh so you can see right here
that we can now send it whatever args I
want and it will do those in a list so I
could send significantly more values in
here than it's up here and that's okay
and that's how your args work again the
asterisk so where does quarks come in
what does KW args mean well instead of
my args let's go star star let's go
Astro gastric or star star my KW args
and let's just go ahead and take a look
and see what these look like let's print
them out grab this variable up here and
again it's the double asterisk this lets
us know that this is a chord and down
here where I'm calling my my definition
I'm going to go ahead and change this up
and I'm going to say a equals 10 and b
equals 20. and then we have return a
let's just take the return a out for
right now and just have it print it and
if I run this you'll see it comes up
with A10 B20 we haven't talked about
dictionaries we didn't cover
dictionaries yet it's a special kind of
set and the way the dictionary works is
you have your index or key and it has a
value and the indexer key is immutable
you can't change it you can delete it
you can add it but you can't change it
and you can change the in value and so
you can see right here we have an index
of a and an index of B and so I could
also do print my works and instead of
doing 0 I can now do a and we'll do
addition we'll do plus my quarks of B at
the wrong button there okay plus my
quirks of B and if we run this of course
you got to make sure this is a string
the a value here is definitely a string
coming in we can do print my quirks of a
plus my quarks of B and you can see that
we get 10 plus 20 equals 30. so this is
just a really cool way to send
information to your function and have it
be able to like you might have all kinds
of stuff in here you need to send once
you send it you can do all your
different processes you can also do if
you remember from before I can do
something like this let's do this if a
in my quarks and E in my quarks then
print my quarks of a plus my quarks of B
and you can see right here if I change
this instead of 2 a I can change it to C
and run it and it'll say hey I've got a
value of C I've got a value of B but
because I a is not in there I'm not
going to do this addition so you start
to get into some logic gates that make
sure you have the data you're processing
in there and what you're working on and
then one last cool thing to remember is
that our definition is an object so like
any other object and we'll talk a little
bit more about objects here in a minute
I can assign it to a variable so I can
do D equals my args quarks and then I
could do D of I'll do a equals 1 comma b
equals two and if I run this I'll go and
run that you'll see our first run which
we already had up here where a C10 B20
and then you'll see I ran it again this
time it has a equals one b equals two
and it sums them together as three so
you can assign this value you can assign
this whole definition to a variable the
final thing we want to touch upon with
our definition and our functions is the
recursive we've already discussed the
whole reason having a definition is I
can now call it from multiple times from
different parts of my program so that if
I know I need to add certain numbers
together I don't have to replace this
code in every time I need that I just
access my definition in a single line so
recursive means the program this
definition calls itself and just like
the while statement you run the risk of
running an indefinite Loop and of course
if you're stuck in an indefinite Loop
that will eventually crash your program
you're running and so we might have
we'll call this definition Rec for
recursive and we want to take in and we
want to do something with it so we might
say hey if n equals 1 print in and
return so when we hit the value of 1 on
N we know this recursive function is
done that's what this is doing but if it
doesn't equal one we might want it to
print in and then we could do something
like this return
recursive of n minus 1. so let's take a
look and see what's going on here the
first thing it does is it says hey if n
equals 1 we're done with this Loop
because it is a loop it's looping in on
itself and what we want to do is we want
to go ahead and print in and then just
return and then we come down here we say
well if it's not equal to 1 we want to
print in and then we want to run this
loop again with n minus 1. so we're
changing our logic gate here's our n n
keeps changing so n starts off at one
value and we keep subtracting and then
we can just do something like this I can
do let's do a recursive and we'll redo a
3 and we'll run this and I get 3 2 1.
why because each time it goes down here
and it subtracts one that goes back into
this then it says okay 3 minus 1 is
equal to 1 no print it out once we
printed it out do n minus 1 and so on
and you can see right here we just do a
simple countdown certainly there's more
complicated scripts you can write but
you can see how the simple recursive
value works we could use this to solve a
factorial problem let's call this
factorial def fact of N and we'll change
this down here so we call it and run it
and if you remember factorial is simply
we take a value we want to return we'll
call this f f equals 1 4 I in range
let's see would it be in range of 1
comma n plus one remember it doesn't
include the last one so we have to add
that extra plus 1 on there for our range
and we simply do f equals F we can
actually do this the python way F times
equals I so f equals F times I and it
just keeps going through and finds out
what all the factorials are and if we do
this return F we can print our factorial
of three there we go and we run this and
we'll get a nice value six so one times
two times three equals 6. we could also
do this as a recursive problem just like
before we need some kind of break that
says hey we're done so we'd say if n
equals one let's just return one if it
doesn't equal one then what we want to
do is we want to return the factorial of
n minus one the other factorial of n
minus 1 times n that's what I want to do
so we take the value we have and we
multiply times a factorial of n minus 1.
so if our value is three we're going to
multiply that times a factorial of 2 and
we take two we multiply that times a
factorial of one well one is one so
you're multiplying one times two and
then back again to 3. and so if we take
out take out this part right here now we
have the same code in factorial using
recursion and it just goes right down
the list right there and if we run this
we'll get the same value 6 just like we
expected and I want to go back a step
quickly go back to Here There we go pry
in range one f equals we did the F times
equals F or so we're going through here
and this one looks pretty good we've
gone through and it adds up the
factorial but as a recursion problem if
you remember correctly this one just
goes to the end we know the exact answer
danger of the recursion one as we go
back here and do a quick undo is this
calling itself and you can see right
here if n equals one and it just keeps
going -1 and minus one and if I run this
we get our six but what if the value in
here is minus three well we keep
subtracting we go minus three minus 4
and so on you can already see there's
going to be a problem and if I run this
it will crash the program because it
gets stuck in a recursive Loop and here
you go it gives me the recursive error
maximum recursive death exceeded in
comparison so we actually have a limit
on there so you got to be real careful
with your recursive functions but
they're also really useful in handy in a
lot of different scripting and
computations I hate to wrap up on an
error so I'll switch it back to three
and run it so I'll have our nice value
of 6. well we want to talk about next
Lambda Lambda is a very useful tool and
especially when we get into what they
call mapping and reducing functions map
and reduce itself is a Hadoop term and
there's an actual scripting code called
mapreduce but it's also a programming
way of thinking so this is a very
important concept or a number of
important Concepts we're going to cover
with the Lambda which means function
Lambda just is a they call it the Lambda
function and how and why it works and
how it's used what we're going to do is
we're going to take our add function
from before we had add a b very simple
function to do we have S equals a plus b
return if I run this it'll add the 10
plus 20 on there 30 just like you would
expect it from our previous definitions
the Lambda function or its bases is it
actually does all of this in one line of
code so that's the first thing we're
going to start with is our very basic
Lambda function the L equal equals
Lambda there's our keyword Lambda
meaning it's a function a comma B and we
get a plus b and so when you see this
our Lambda function I can print L and
then we can do 10 20. this does exactly
what we just did with the add function
it takes the 10 and the 20 it comes
across as a tuple there's our Tuple
being sent in the Tuple is a b and then
simply returns a plus b whatever's on
the right hand side so the Lambda is a
simple function now we can get really
complicated by using a function for the
function but you can just put your
simple function here A plus b l equals
Lambda a comma B colon a plus b and we
get our nice print L for Lambda 1020. we
can also do some kind of filtering in
here so we'll do let's create ourselves
a list here's a list of letters and
let's say I want to take this list and I
want to filter it out so we'll give it a
variable here for our Lambda we'll just
use x x is very commonly used in Lambda
and then we'll put over here x in and
let's say if you remember from before
when we did the vowels we had our aeiou
and if we run this and I go ahead and
print L pop that back in there and run
forgot we're doing a filter function I
forgot the whole of it we're going to do
a list and we're going to do this list
of a filter so we'll need brackets for
the list I'll have my filter and then
I'll need brackets for the filter what's
going into the filter and the filter
comes in here we're going to put the
Lambda in there so let's break this down
I'm creating a list from that list I'm
filtering out and I'm going to use the
Lambda function and the Lambda function
says Hey for each entity in this list I
want to know if x is in a e i o u and if
it is in a e i o u then at that point I
want to go ahead and add it to my list
and so here we are adding it on to the
LST over filtering the LST and we're
returning the value to go into this list
what you can do is you could imagine
that instead of this being a list of
these it might be a row in your database
you're processing so you have a lot of
data coming in and you can see right
here it filters it out it gets rid of
the B and the F and we end up with our
aeoa it filters it out so imagine that
you're sending it a row in your database
so for each row we want to know what the
the Lambda is and it processes each
character in this data this could easily
be an array or columns you know from
your row we might have column a name
first name last name address and you
want to know which one of these is part
of something else so we've covered a
filter what I want to cover next is
mapping and a lot of times when I work
with filters and maps and I'm working
with data the terminology map when
you're thinking map is everything you
can do to one line or one row in your
database you don't need all the other
rows to look at it so mapping is another
tool and the actual use of map with
Lambda will do a result equals equals
map Lambda and then we're going to take
each character in there and we're going
to just go ordin we're going to convert
it to its ASCII code and we're going to
add one to it so we're just going to
adjust it to each one and so I forgot
and took out my actual list of course
pipe charm already remembers it unless I
restart the pycharm environment so it'd
still work if I ran it so we have our
list a b e f o a then we're going to get
a result let's go ahead and print the
result and run it and you can see right
here result and we'll convert it into a
list and so when we print the result we
get
bcfgpb I'm guessing you know a the next
one up would be b b the next one up
would be c e the next one up would be F
and so on and again when we're talking
about Maps the mapping part of a program
it's whatever you can do on one line of
data and I bring that up and I keep
saying that over and over and over again
because when you touch upon data
processing and especially Big Data this
is how we're able to cover Tera and
terabytes of data is is we process one
row at a time and that's the mapping
they call that that is literally the
mapping we are mapping something if I
look at this row of data I don't need to
know anything else about the database
other than this row of data and that's
how I'm going to map it and if you're
going to map something you need to go
ahead and reduce it because if you have
a ton of different rows in a database or
whatever you're working with in this
case we're just working with characters
in a list we want to reduce it to
something everybody can read something
you can process at a glance we do need
to go ahead and import reduce so we'll
do that from the function tools import
reduce that makes it much more legible
instead of doing Fung tools dot reduce
and then we'll do our results equals
reduce Lambda X of Y X plus the Y of our
list and all we're saying here is for
each element that we look at we're going
to divide this up and then we're just
going to keep adding it on to our list
and then if we print out the result we
run it you'll see we end up with a b e f
o a and that's from the original test
remember this Lambda result does not fit
into here this is the list is being fit
into here in fact let's go ahead and
remove the map I'm going to keep the map
up there and reduce so we mapped it and
then we take so we're processing each
individual character in our map we're
processing each individual character in
this list changing it tacking it onto
the list or Returns the differences and
then we're going to bring them all
together so we're doing a reduction
reducing it into one string down here so
we've covered a lot we've had our
functions so we looked at our Lambda the
next thing we want to look at is modules
and we've already been looking at that
without even knowing it and we'll start
with I'm going to call this I renamed
this one mod1.py this is stuff we
already did earlier so we had our Prime
of a our even number of a def Prime of a
equals 4i and range 2 comma a if the
remainder of a divided by I equals 0
print numbers not prime return number is
prime and then we also did even print
number is even print number is odd so
this is something we did earlier we
created these definitions to let us know
whether it's even or odd I've changed
the name to
mod1.py and this is going to be saved in
the same folder as our scratch so this
script that I'm going to write in here
is in the same folder you can also put
it in your library so if you have your
environment and you have all your
library folders which has all the other
default python including the modules we
imported this will access either one and
what we can simply do on this is we can
now import our mod 1. and so we can do
from Mod 1 Import everything so that's
going to import our two definitions it's
going to import Prime and it's going to
put import even and so anything we do in
here can now access that so we can now
do n equals integer Let's do an enter
input and enter number so we're going to
have it input a number and it's going to
force it to be an integer so now we have
our n and we'll simply do print and
let's take a look over here we had from
our module we had print Prime of a or
even of a those are our two options on
there that's what we had brought in so I
could do print Prime and we're going to
send n back there and I can also do
print or actually there's no prints
there's no return statement so it's just
Prime of N and even of n so those are
two things we imported and if we run
that it's going to ask me to enter a
number we'll enter in 3 or 23 in this
case and you'll say numbers prime number
is odd so 23 is a prime number and it's
also an odd number is it even or odd
this can be very complicated because you
could also do you know add a select in
here run this if I have a selection of a
or b or whatever but at this point
you're now writing modules for your
script and you can see how you can
easily organize a very lengthy program
by having your different modules built
outside of what you're working on so
you're not you don't have this huge
length of like hundreds of lines of code
to read through you only have the little
piece you're working on and you can
share these modules that way if you're
working as a group just like we imported
math you know very or numpy numpy is NP
we can now share these modules with
other people who can then utilize them
for their projects let's go ahead and
close out of this and clear up my area
of I'm working with and we're going to
jump into the next big topic that is not
meaning that I just knocked my coffee
over and Spilled it all over my desk but
object oriented programming and we're
going to start with the theory there's a
lot of theory behind oops it's been
around for since the 90s very Central to
just about any programming language out
there and earlier when I pointed out
that your functions we do the def
statement def whatever your function
name is but those are objects we can
actually set them to variables and so
object oriented programming is what this
is all centered on we have an object
everything in Python is an object if you
look at it programming Paradigm that
focuses on objects every instance in
Python is an object so like I just said
everything you do in Python you have an
object you're looking at an object has
attributes so we have data that's
describing the object and it has
Behavior methods on the attributes these
are your definitions your functions and
your tributes are your your list your
arrays your numpy array your variables
all those are attributes and so for
example if we have a BMW I don't drive a
BMW myself I actually have a beatable
pickup truck given where I live I would
prefer my trip pickup truck to the BMW
but if I live someplace else I would
definitely like a nice BMW to drive
around so for an example you have a year
manufacturer maximum speed those are all
attributes of your BMW and for Behavior
you might have you might display the
speed because the speed is always
changing so there you go those are all
behavior is you accelerate the amount of
gas going into the engine changes as you
push on the brake you're pushing on the
brake is a behavior and it's changing
the speed of the car so we define a
class class is a collection of similar
objects so for example a car we have BMW
we have Ford we have an Audi The
Inheritance mechanism for a new class to
use the features of another class so we
have a number of different things
inheritance we might have our class
which is vehicles and then under
Vehicles we might have Cars and Cars
inherits all the different stuff from
Vehicles so we have inheritance so you
can create a class from another class
the feature preventing data from direct
access is called encapsulation so when
we have our object programming we have
integers we looked at integers you can't
actually access integer you assign a
variable that has all the different
features and functions of an integer but
you don't access the actual integer
object you can't which generally you
don't you have it encapsulated so that
it is never altered and polymorphism is
a feature of using the same function in
multiple ways so you can think of this
in in our example of vehicles and cars
we might also have vehicles and bicycles
well bicycles accelerate very different
than a car does a car you step on the
gas a bicycle you step on the pedal both
of them have a similar acceleration you
want to play more of that function so
that it works the same for both of those
but it does something very different so
let's go ahead and create our class so
we'll call it car we have our semicolon
here which says that whatever comes
after this is indented as part of the
class car now there's some things we're
leaving out here you'll almost always
see brackets and variables in there
we'll look at that in just a moment
let's just start with the class car and
we might have car type let's give it an
attribute this particular attribute is a
car type and we'll set it equal to
manual and this is a global variable
we've set up on here that's used
throughout the setup throughout the
class car and then we want to create a
Def and a very special definition
remember that's a function for diff and
we call it init it stands for initialize
and we put a double underscore before it
and a double score underscore after it
what that means is when I create this
class an instance of the class not the
class itself but I create this instance
of this class I create a variable equal
to car this initializes it and self
means that it's referring to itself
whenever you see self in the class
you're referring to that instance and
we'll look at that a little bit more
closer in just a minute so hopefully if
you're confused we'll be able to help
you with that we'll go ahead and give it
a pass a couple variables speed so when
we initiate class we're going to pass it
year in speed and then self is just part
of the what's passed into the definition
and we'll go ahead and do
self.year equals year and self dot speed
equals speed so up here we have a global
variable and down here we have an
instance feature I use variable and
feature kind of interchangeably but
certainly feature is probably the more
appropriate word but they are variables
also either way they're the same thing
and then let's go ahead and create a
it's called a static method and you set
it that by doing the at symbol here and
we'll
static method this is a command it lets
us know that this is not specific to an
object or the class is variable so this
is independent of our specific
initiation and with this we're going to
do a welcome and we'll just have it do a
print down here we'll go print oh
welcome to the car showroom kind of
is our oops I forgot to put the deaf in
front of Welcome this is tab so when we
do this when I have our instance this
never changes it's a static method it's
always going to do the same thing it
doesn't matter where it's coming from it
doesn't need to access any other
information in the any other features in
the class car or in whatever initiated
variable I have and then we'll do
something a little bit more traditional
def get speed automatically does the
self and in this case we're just going
to do print maximum speed is self dot
speed now remember we initiated it so
here's our self dot speed self means
it's the instance we're creating it's
not the actual class but the instance
and we're going to print that out and so
let's take a look at that and just see
how this all comes together I did forget
one piece of the of the puzzle just like
we have a static method I'm going to do
this up here we also have what's called
class specific so when you have a class
specific method you denote that with
class method now remember the static
method doesn't care anything about
what's in the class who doesn't care
about the initiation he has all the
information it needs with the class
method we need to go ahead and use have
information this class specific and we
did that up here when I did class and I
did car type equals manual so that's the
feature that we can access underneath
this title then we'll create a
definition here and we'll call this type
we'll just do CLS because it's a class
method that's what the CLS stands for
and then we're going to do print we're
in a nice showroom and we say these cars
R comma CLS dot car type so the CLS just
refers to the class class are variables
without the self in front so when I have
a class or a feature underneath class
any instance I create is going to have
car type equals manual where when I
initiate it and I have self any feature
like self.year self.speed is going to be
just that instance has that feature and
whatever value we put into it and then
we have a static method which only
accesses the static method it doesn't
have any other information coming into
it from either the class or external and
then you can see here we have type class
denoted by CLS and we can print the
class type and then we have the self
there's ourself our most basic
definition get speed and the way this
works is we have our B of let's do our
here's our BMW so our BMW equals make
sure there's no spaces in front of it is
going to equal car and we have our car
class back up here yeah I did it all
lower case a lot of times car the
classes you want to start with a capital
letter you don't have to but that just
is like a kind of a programmer standard
on there so you can remember that it is
a class versus a variable which we start
with lowercase and if you go up here to
initial we have self which it
automatically sends because this is a
part of the car and then we have year
and speed and so we want to go ahead and
send those in there we'll do a 2018 and
we'll say has a maximum speed of 155 I
don't usually living where I do I don't
go over 75 or 80 at the tops due to the
particular laws we have and we'll do a
forward in this particular fort on their
showroom or 2016 and maybe your Ford has
a maximum speed of 140. so now we've
created two instances and if I do BMW
dot get speed you'll see here that it
doesn't the self which I put in here
isn't needed because it already pulls
the cell phone that is the the instance
it's saying the BMW which I called it is
pulling in BMW on here and all the
features with self are pulled into it
also so if I run this you'll see down
here that it pulls up the speed it says
maximum speed is 155 for our BMW and
let's say we want to know about the Ford
maybe we'll do Ford get speed and we run
this and the maximum speed for the Ford
is 140 and of course we're looking at
the little ticker tape of the car and
Along Comes the guy who says hey do you
want to buy a car and we'll do the car
welcome and if we run that it says
messed up on this because it's a
and we do the car welcome this is
welcome to the car showroom maximum
speed is 140 on the car you're looking
at our salesman's come up and approached
us and then finally we might be looking
around the showroom and saying hey what
kind of showroom is this what are you
guys showing to me we can do car type we
see that it comes up these cares typo
there these cars are and then it looks
at the car type and says manual so
you're in the manual car showroom now
this is all great you have your class
car let me go ahead and just get rid of
some of this stuff take it back and not
a knot up take out keep our B and W and
forward down there and so with our class
car we now have under there an init
we'll keep the init where we put in the
year and the speed and we set that I've
taken out my static method but I do want
to add in let's go back and put the get
speed back in itself get speed and we'll
just print like we had before maximum
speed and because we put it in as a for
the instance we'll do self Dot
so right now we have our basic class car
that looks pretty good but what if we
were talking about remember we had like
these models are all standard these
models are all whatever what if I want
to have a class sedan so
just sedans but I wanted to have all the
features of the car I don't want to have
to do a economy a sedan a four-wheel
drive I don't want to redo all the work
I do in car because the get speed is
going to be the same the year and
everything else is going to be the same
what I can do is we can do an
inheritance and that means when I do a
class sedan of car this inherit
everything from car so everything I have
above in car is inherited so any
instance I create a sedan uses all the
values in car and we can do we can
change some things on here but let me
just show you how this works to begin
with instead of doing I can do this part
right here let me just do
BMW dot get speed so I still have my car
class so if I run this you will see
indent error because I forgot I created
the this here let's go pass is just a
fancy way of putting a placeholder here
saying the code is here but don't do
anything select process maximum speed is
155 and what happens instead of a car we
do a sedan and we run this I still get
maximum speed is 155. well sedan doesn't
have that in there but sedan inherited
everything from car so when we look at
this I have maximum speed equals
self.speed and I admit the
initialization is the same self.year
self.speed on there now we can also do
something like this with sedan I can
take to copy all this over generally you
don't just do a pass here the very least
you need your init file in this and so
here's my initialization and so with
sedan we're going to do something like
this I'm going to go super.net year
comma speed and what I'm telling it is
it comes in as okay I'm initializing a
sedan this is my initialization code but
we're going to go to the class that this
inherited from which is our car and
we're going to do the init there this
basically comes up here and says okay
this is our init this is how we're going
to initialize this but in addition to
that what I want to do is I also want to
do something like this print this is a
sedan and so now when I run this our BMW
initializes as a sedan it does the super
so it uses all of the init code
underneath our class car and then in
addition to that is whatever I want to
do in this case I want to just print
this is a sedan so you can see it prints
this is a sedan and then when I run get
speed it still utilizes that from the
original class so now I also have the
speed and the initialization all under
my original class car I'm not recreating
it retyping it copying it down there and
just like we have defs appear under
class we might have certain definitions
which are very specific to the sedan so
maybe we have open trunk so we'll put
that in there there's our definition for
open trunk and all it does is print open
trunk and so I can do BMW dot open trunk
and if I run this my BMW now can open
the trunks now it has additional
functionality that cars doesn't we can
see this if I do four dot open trunk and
if you guessed it'd give us a error
you're correct card doesn't have an open
trunk I'm sorry it's an error this four
maybe it's a Ford truck it doesn't have
a trunk so it can't open it so this is
only if it's a sedan does it have open
trunk underneath of it and this just
adding being able to add new definitions
is our polymorphism we can polymorph our
class to do things the original class
couldn't do and we can go ahead we could
take this oh let's let's change this up
a little bit here we'll initialize this
with name and then self dot name equals
name and instead of having setting the
speeds here we'll just give we'll just
say that this particular Individual Car
maximum speed of
150 for get speed and we'll do the same
thing down here we'll have our instead
of a sedan let's do this oh let's just
take this completely out of here we'll
take our sedan and the sedan we'll have
a speed of 150. but instead of us yeah
sedan that works we'll just do sedan and
then maybe we'll also have another one
that is an SUV and so our SUV class they
all have a maximum speed of 120 name
this s u v and so now that we have these
two classes they're both inheriting from
Cars so when we send something to them
we're going to send name self.name and
then we have def get speed which is
going to return 150 class SUV maximum
speed is 120. so we're storing the name
underneath the each instance of it and
then we're also going to get a different
speed each time let's do a list we'll do
a car list here's our list of cars
there's our brackets for our list and
then I'm going to do something kind of
fun here here's a sedan now the sedan is
the class so that's an object so I can
make a list of that object and in that
particular object we're going to give it
a name and the name of this one is going
to be it's a Camry very common car out
there and then I'm going to create a
second object and it's going to be an
SUV class now remember we'd also did
variables as definitions certainly you
can put anything that's an object into a
variable so these are a list of classes
on here with their calls and the SUV
we're going to do I guess Scorpio not
too familiar with the Scorpio car but I
guess it's one of the common SUVs in
certain areas so now I have a list of
two classes and these classes are both
initialized the first one with Camry and
with Scorpio and from before we can do
four car and car list so we're going to
do each car and then we're just going to
do something simple like print in this
case car dot name and kind of a fun one
we'll add the plus sign in and the
brackets and the colon and give me just
a second to put this together comma n
equals double brackets this is basically
we're telling it don't print a new line
I want to print the car followed by car
dot accelerate so remember we had
actually we did to get speed so we'll do
we'll stick with get speed control copy
get speed put in our double brackets I'm
just going to add a space of here and
here oops actually goes at the beginning
so if I run this it should go all the
way through this list here's our for
Loop remember this how we talked about
iterating through a list of objects
there's our car list and as we go
through we see Scorpio we have our Camry
Camry is maximum speed 150 Scorpio
maximum speed 120. so we put together a
nice set of polymorphism of classes we
polymorphed our our car class into a
sedan and into an SUV so they each have
these print out a very different thing
or have a very different get speed
functionality but they both inherit the
initial def from car we're going to take
on seven parts or seven code challenges
that you can do to take all the basics
we've covered so far in Python and see
how to apply them and we'll start with
part one part one we want to go ahead
and see if we can print the number of
occurrences of each character in a
string and this would be a good time to
pause the video so you can actually try
to solve it on your own before we go
ahead and give you the solution we came
up with now remember the there's always
multiple solutions to any of these
challenges so if you come up with a
different one that's great you know it
just means you're thinking on there the
first thing we want to do is we want to
go ahead and get an input so we want to
go ahead and pull up an input for our
word that we're going to type in and
then we're looking for the number of
characters in a string so we need some
way to track it and we have what we call
a dictionary now if you remember we
briefly touched upon the dictionary a
dictionary is denoted with two brackets
and it comes in the form of a key so
you'll have your key code and then that
key code is set to a value so the value
can change the key code cannot and if we
had brackets around this could initiate
it if you already know your initial keys
and values with something that looks
like this and we can also here's our D
assign them as we go and so we'd have
our key and then this would equal our
value and what's nice about these two
setups is that we have a key code which
could represent our characters and then
we have the value which is going to
represent the count hopefully you
remember map reduce we're thinking map
and reduce this is such a common
question that comes up in map and reduce
so we're going to map all our characters
out and then count them and reduce that
to in a huge mapreduce program you would
actually do each document how to have a
summation and then that would be sent
and brought together and then reduced to
just a single representation of it so
we're doing kind of the end part where
we're just reducing this word so here we
have our dictionary and then we want to
go ahead and do a four eye Loop for I
and S so our input is s and this will
iterate over each character in the
string and the next thing I want to know
is do we already have D in our
dictionary in this case we're looking at
each of our I so if I and D so if it's
already in there then we can simply do
this we can simply do D of I and then
you can do the plus equals and then of
course we're just adding one to X or
incrementing it by one now if it doesn't
exist in the dictionary and you try to
do that you'll get an error it'll say no
key value you there so now we have to do
a thing where if I is not in D we do
simply D of I and we initialize it with
one keep it simple and then finally
we've got all our different things we
can just print D and if I run this let's
go ahead and take that and run it comes
up says enter a string and we'll do
hello I'll hit enter and you'll see I
have h capital H equals 1 lowercase e
equals one L equals two there's two L's
and O equals one you can also if you're
trying to look at a little bit clearer
you could do before key and D we could
do something like this print D of key
and you gotta remember it doesn't
actually print the key unless you tell
it to so here's the key in the D of key
so I can also do it this way see if we
can pick another a better word on here
and you can actually do a full phrase in
here so uh welcome to Python and hit
enter and you'll see that we have W1 e
has two L has one c one o three m one
there's two spaces T is two p is one y
has one H and so on so this is a very
simple set of Loops but it covers a lot
of interesting key points that you'll
use throughout any kind of big data or
map and reduce program so let's move to
part two or challenge two let me just
clear my palette so we have a nice
palette and what we're going to do for
part two is we're going to insert an
element at the kth position of a list
and again you know pause it if you need
to let's go ahead and create our list
and in this case we're going to do just
a standard list we'll do some mixed
elements we'll have like 23 it looks
like they sent me an example of the list
let me just grab that so let's do 23 hey
oh 89 python so we have a nice list
there with one two three four five
objects or zero through four if you're
thinking indexing and let's go ahead and
do this we'll print let's just print the
original list comma list and then we
need our input in equals input and I
guess we need to put where we're going
to enter it at so it says input and
let's do enter on index between they
have Let's see we can do this a couple
different ways but let's say we do zero
which would put it at the beginning and
and then at the end how would you get to
know the end well we could do this plus
string of length in this case length of
list and remember we don't want to type
in the actual well I guess I could type
in the actual end so it could be zero or
it could be the very end of the list so
this n should give us a nice input and
then let's have an object or we'll just
call it K let's put this above sometimes
it's nice to put these in a different
order k equals input let's go ahead and
have it enter on element and so this
will automatically be a string that we
enter here I'm going to go ahead and
just add a space there so it stays on
the same line if you have a larger
screen this might look better if it goes
down a line but in this case I want to
go ahead and just keep that in the same
line and we'll do this on here I'll do
plus and add a space and this will be
our element n and K for the actual
integer and we want to make sure this
stays as an integer so so let's go ahead
and take this whole thing and add
integer at the beginning it's for our
index integer at the end so now we have
our input we're going to add an element
in this case it's going to always be a
string unless we want to try to convert
it and then we're going to enter in
where it's going to go and so how do we
get there how do we put that in that
list and so there is actually a number
of ways you can actually do an insert
but let's say we don't have the list
insert command make it a little hard on
us let's go ahead and do this let's go
ahead and do a list of pinned and we're
going to append this case k that's the
entity we entered in here so if we
pretend not to do the list insert and we
have the append we can append our value
on to the end of our list and what we're
going to do and again there's like so
many different solutions for this I mean
if I was just doing an insert into my
list I would just do an insert but let's
say sometimes you have to do other than
finding out the spot on there you might
be comparing the values or doing
something else going on so we can do is
we can go for I in range 0 comma length
of list so we're going to create an
integer that comes in here and just
starts at the zero index so I for index
and just Pages through all of our
objects in the list and we want to know
is if I is greater than we had our K
value now if you did like I did up here
zero you could also do K value equals
one so this gets a little tricky on your
input if you're talking about your end
client do they know to start 0 as play 0
or do they start with Place one so that
might change your coding and how you put
this together those are things you'd
want to think about and we're going to
do temp equals list of I so we go ahead
and we look at our list and we say okay
I'm going to pull this object off I'll
create a temp here list of I equals n
and we're going to swap in our n value
and then we'll do n equals temp so let's
take a look at this and I have if I is
greater than K and since we're starting
with zero we'll go do I is greater than
or equal to K that's just because we're
still starting with a zero instead of
one and we take we go ahead and create a
temp variable that goes to that pointer
list of I then equals n that's our last
element in this case it's the one we
entered and then we set n equal to Temp
so we take this and we take whatever's
in that position we put it in Temp and
then we just go all the way through and
what happens is it will just keep
replacing that value all the way to the
end and let's go ahead and see what that
looks like before we do this I guess we
have to print out an answer so we'll
come down here we'll go print and our
updated list comma and this is just list
let's go ahead and run this and we'll
tell down here and let's enter in hello
and I always like to do the extremes we
have 0 and 5. so let's go into 0 and
enter and we have our list which is
original 23 all the way to Python and
now it says hello and puts it right at
the beginning if you're going to do that
you should also test out the end of the
list so what happens if I put in 5 and
then it comes up and you see it puts
hello at the end what happens if we put
in 4 double check here we go L4 and it
comes up on place number four and I'll
do one more test on this just because I
really don't like things going out the
door unless I know they work and we'll
put in one and you'll see here 0 1 2 3
and so on and there's our hello and you
can see here we had a nice setup on that
we have our input and we just go through
it's really important to note that we're
iterating through each value and we're
seeing if something important is going
to need to change that value this could
be almost anything this could be that
you need to alter not only insert the
value but maybe increment everything
past it with plus one or something
there's all kinds of things that can
come up little weird logic that you
wouldn't think of until you start
messing with it Challenger part three
check if the substring is present in a
string without using the find method I
remember back in the 90s this was
Central to all of your programming was
to do all these little things now of
course they have fine built into the
functionality so string we need to have
our input we're going to input a string
and we're going to input a substring and
we'll call them St for string ring and
sub for substring and I'm going to jump
ahead a little bit here and then come
back because we want to look at
something let's do count equals zero and
then we're going to do our Loop for I in
range 0. we want to start with position
zero and then we want to go to what
that's where the question comes in well
we could do the length of the string now
there's a problem with this and that is
that the substring might be five letters
long so if I go to the length of the
string I'm actually comparing the
substring to something that isn't even
there so I'm going past the end of the
string it's not really worth doing so
how do we figure out that number well we
can do L equals length of our substring
so now we have a value for how long the
substring is and we simply take the 0 to
length of string minus L and then we
want to add 1 on there so remember that
this length it goes exactly to that
length without including it so we have
to add the plus 1 in there to include
the very end of that so 0 to the length
of the string so the next question is
how do we know we have it well if or a
substring equals string and we want to
start from position I and we want to go
to I plus L the length of the substring
so if they're equal we'll print count
plus equals one our increment of one and
we'll do print substring here's our
placeholder s for a string found at
position and then here's our placeholder
for a number or D in this case and we'll
go ahead and give it just a space off of
here oh no that's fine we don't need a
space on that and then we have our
ampersina percent sign and our two bolt
so here's our Tuple we want sub comma I
so that put that right in there this
will tell us that it's in there each
time it finds a substring we're counting
it then we print it out that it's part
of it a little redundant because you'll
just print out the same thing over and
over again and then we can do if count
equals zero we can print substring not
found and of course an else statement
else print and we'll do substring
substring here's our place marker again
s found another placeholder D times and
then we can if you're going to do your
placeholders of course you have to do
your Tuple at the end and we have our
sub comma in this case count so let's
see what that looks like when it runs oh
before we do that let's just walk
through it so let's take a walk through
what we just did so we have for I equals
range we had to kind of fiddle a little
bit with the length to make sure we got
all the way to the end but we didn't go
past it for finding our sub in the range
of the string simple if statement says
hey it's here count plus equals one
let's go ahead and print our substring
found this will be very repetitive so I
don't even really know wouldn't normally
put this in here just to keep printing
it and then it says if count equals zero
we found none print substring not found
and else substring s found D times with
our count so let's go go ahead and run
this and here it goes enter our string
welcome to Simply learn I'm going to hit
enter and we're going to look for the
let's go to and it gave me an error so
what happened here and I of course get
an error hopefully you caught this error
when I was putting it together this
should be a colon not a comma this is a
straight list so that's why you got to
remember what rate you're working in and
it does happen and we'll go ahead and
run this again and we'll do welcome to
Simply Learn Type in our two and it
comes up and says substring two found
one times substring found at position
eight so now we know what position it's
at and we also have how many times it
was found and since I was just talking
about numpy arrays let's do Challenger
part four find the index for the inth
repetition of a number and a numpy array
so let's go ahead and import our numpy
as NP you'll see that very standard and
I went ahead and created an array or a
team in the back did so we are going to
create our variable AR set to a numpy
array and it's just one two four one
twenty three one two three four so it's
kind of a random set of numbers on here
and this here we can build this and at
this point you should be trying to think
about how to do it yourself and let's go
ahead and I'll just paste this in here
we're going to print the original array
just so you can double check it in our
output and we're going to do our input
num equals an integer and then give a
value for the number for your input so
we'll have our num we're going to look
for and let's do this if num in R so the
first thing we want to know is even is
in there there's always a chance you
might not even have that number in there
initiating or doing initial case so if
we're looking for kind of the base case
of do we want to even do anything if
it's not in there so if number in AR
first thing you want to do is check
otherwise it's not worth processing and
then let's do this so we want to ask the
question what is the index for the nth
repetition so we got to find out what
repetition the user wants and we'll go
ahead and create another input in give a
value for n which is our repetition or
repeat so give a value for n or the
repeat on here now at this point there's
so many different ways to solve this we
could iterate through but we're going to
create and you'll hear the term mask let
me just type that out for you or you're
masking something masking means that we
create a series of values in this case
we're going to create a bunch of ones
and we're going to say it equals NP so
here's our numpy array where our input
array equals our number so this is going
to return a numpy array of either ones
or zeros then we can actually test it
and see what's in there now there's
other ways we could just iterate through
the numpy array usually when you're
working with numpy arrays you try not to
iterate across them the whole purpose of
the numpy array is to let it Leverage
The backend code so you're not wasting
as much resources and you know what
let's go ahead and print one out just so
you can see what that looks like what
this masking does so NP where R equals
number let's go ahead and run that and
here's our setup let's do enter in the
number one and value for in repeat uh it
doesn't really matter because we're not
doing anything with that yet we'll put
in three and if you look at the output
of this mask we've created it's set up
in returns an array and the array is 0 3
5 9 15 18. it returns all the positions
of our number in the array so here's NP
where R equals number and then we just
called it one if you print one out you
can see we just get a nice list of
indexes and this is really useful to us
let's go back in here and then we can
very simply on the indexes do if we have
our n and we'll do less than or equal to
the length of our one and remember this
is a tuple coming in this array so we
have the first part is the actual
indexes and the second part is our D
type so we really want to do the one of
zero and this is important if you
haven't worked with numpy arrays or even
if you work with them a lot sometimes
you just do a quick printout to find out
what it is you're looking at so you can
remember the format on there and we'll
do this if it's less than or equal to
the length of one is zero then we can
simply print one over zero position and
then on here we want to do since that's
also itself is array we want to do the n
minus one because remember we start with
zero so if we wanted to find out in the
how many is in there or you know what
the position it is we're counting one
two three but the array is 0 1 2. so we
have to put that n minus 1 in there and
of course if we don't find it we'll do
an else statement and we'll print there
aren't and then we'll go ahead and put
down a placeholder just we can keep
track of it occurrences of one just keep
it simple this time and then finally
we'll go back here and you hit our
original if number in the r we of course
have an else print that is not in there
boom and let's go ahead and run that and
we have our list down here let me move
this thing back up so we can see what
the Run looks like we'll look for let's
look for one and we wanted to repeat him
a fourth and it returns it in position
nine there we go and if we went up here
and entered in let's enter in just a
random number I don't see the number 33
so we'll put 33 in there 33 not in the
array so it doesn't even go through
because we put that initial test right
at the beginning that says hey if it's
not in here don't even bother and then
we went through and counted them now you
probably found your own solution very
Central to our solution was the where
statement where it's going to map out
the indexes of this occurrence where R
equals number and this is part of
masking there's all kinds of ways to
mask your data usually you mask the
whole array across something when you
talk about masking in this case we're
just returning a simple array where it
lists the indexes let's go ahead and
clean our screen here for part five
generate a dictionary that contains
pairs such as I comma I times I where I
integer is between 1 and an entered
value sometimes I'll break these up if
I'm for readability so we'll do that
there we go so we're going to generate a
dictionary that's the first thing we
need to do and we need a value entered
so let's go ahead and do both of those
and there's a couple ways to generate a
dictionary earlier we did the two
squiggly brackets you can also just do D
equals dictionary if I run this you'll
see that it works in s for a number let
me go ahead and enter in four it
processes I could have easily just have
also done this with the double brackets
that's the same thing so if you see
something dictionary you could also
these are equivalent statements D equals
brackets and D equals dictionary or that
dictionary object and we'll do 4i in
range 1 in plus one so there's a number
we entered and in our dictionary we're
going to do D of I there's our key
equals and our value I times I and you
could have also done since this is just
squaring it we could have also done
squared that's the same thing as I times
I squared but we'll go ahead and do I
times I and then we'll simply because
you want to see what your end is is
print D and let's go ahead and run this
and we'll shift this up just a little
bit it says enter a number we'll enter 3
and if I run that or if I hit enter on
there I get 1 1 so 1 squared is one two
squared is 4 3 squared is 9 and you
could go on as far as you wanted on
there I could enter in a significantly
larger number but it goes up to whatever
my range is on that this is again an
example of dictionary how to build a
dictionary in simple ways on there all
right let's go ahead and clear our
screen for part six uh write a program
which takes two digits X Y as input and
generates a matrix the element value in
the ith row and the JS column of the
array should be I times J there's a lot
of ways to do this we're going to do
this as a list of lists my first thought
though would be to put this in numpy
because numpy can do this very there's a
lot of automated ways to do this in
numpy but let's go ahead and look at the
back end how would you do this into a
regular list so before we start solving
this problem how do we get our data we
have two inputs what if I wanted to have
just one input where I have you enter X
comma Y what would that look like take
out the space there because I could
cause an issue well there's a couple
ways to do this one is if we want to
generate an X Y this number is going to
return a tuple for whatever I do we
could do something like this so on here
we're entering a string with two
integers how do we convert those well we
can do integer X for X in string dot
split this is a really kind of a fun
shorthand for python for iterating
through our setup so what we got here is
we're going to first of all split our
string so here's our string it comes in
with two comma 3 and then we take and we
split it by the comma and for each
entity in that split we want to return
the into major of that entity in this
case we've labeled it X and so this
should go through and do x y and it
should return an X integer and a y
integer and let's just see what that
looks like let me just go ahead and
print X comma Y and let's go ahead and
run that and here our X Y is we go 3
comma two hit enter and it enters 3
comma 2. Now if you're putting out a
full package what happens if you have
somebody who's overzealous and does
something like this 345 3 enter we're
going to get a an unpack too many values
so this returned this huge list of
numbers I typed in and gave me an error
so you got to remember that when you're
doing these different inputs you might
sort it out and just look for the first
two of them there's all kinds of
different ways to do this so now we have
our X Y if you went ahead and just did
the inter X and enter y that's okay and
we want to generate a list so our list
that we're going to put together is
going to be and again we're doing some
nested stuff here which is a lot of fun
we're going to create a two by two
Matrix and so we're going to have for 0
for column and range Y and for Row in
range X so what we're doing here is this
is going to put a 0 in each of these in
here and then this is simply column is
our for column column is nothing more
than a placeholder I could have done for
C in range y same thing with rho that's
because it has to have a value that
shows up here and we're just going to
fill everything with zero and let's go
ahead and print this print list we run
this and you'll see here's our inner X Y
we'll do three comma 3 and we end up
with zero zero zero zero zero zero zero
zero zero here's our two iterations done
the pythonian way it's going to return
we have the square brackets on the end
so it's returning an array and for the
first one we're going to put 0 for
column in range of Y and then we're
going to repeat that again for rho and
range of X instead of 0 we can simply do
this I can do column times rho and if we
run this we'll see here's our X Y let's
do three comma 3 again that way it's not
too big on there and we end up with zero
zero zero zero one two zero two four and
we might get a little fancy in this and
do oh you know what let's do it this way
import numpy as in p and then maybe
we'll do numpy array equals NP dot array
of and then we'll enter in our list that
we created and then let's print in PA
remember that when I say here Matrix I
automatically go right in for the numpy
array so we'll enter our three comma 3
and you can see here that numpy is
designed for doing matrixes and so we
have zero times zero zero times one zero
times two one times zero one times one
one times two and so on so we create a
nice little Matrix of I to J and then we
put it into numpy just because we can
and numpy has such a nicer format on
there so so let's go ahead and clear our
palette let's move on to part seven and
in part seven we're going to find the
hcf of a two numbers using recursion and
hcf if you don't know what hcf is it's
highest common factor or denominator of
two numbers using recursion I couldn't
remember it I had to look that up so
let's do a definition we'll create a
little function hcf and what comes into
there is going to be X and Y and what I
want to know is we want the highest one
so we'll do if first of all Y is not
equal to zero if it's equal to zero you
you don't want to divide it anything
because they'll give you an error
anything divided by zero and let's take
that and we're going to just return hcf
of Y comma X and here's a remainder of Y
so hcfy of x a remainder of Y so we're
looking for this is just the remainder
so it's going to return the remainder on
here on this else we want to return X
and so we need our input on this before
we we go any further so let's grab a
input and we'll do the same kind of
input we did before we're entering X and
Y enter two positive integers and this
is just from a previous example so we'll
just go ahead and grab the integer X for
x and in this case it's not string keep
it this string on there s t and have our
two integers here from before keep it
simple and then let's just go ahead and
combine it all into one line pythonian
way if you can put it into one easy to
read line then you should do so so we're
going to print hcff of placeholder D and
placeholder D is also is placeholder D
and this is our X our Y and then we're
going to just print out the return value
of our hcf of x y and let's go ahead and
run this we're going to enter in two
positive numbers let's go 12 and 18. and
so the hcf of 12 and 18 is 6. that would
be our most common denominator let's go
ahead and clear out part 7 and then
bonus we are going to throw in a part 8
quick sort so we have a bonus round part
eight quick sort and we're going to
positive list of
integers so we're going to do a quick
sort on positive list of integers on
here there's like so many different ways
to do different sortings on this one of
the ways to do it is to look at a list
and then partition that list and then
you go through that partition and you
sort it and then you sort a smaller list
and a small list and so on and so on so
that's what we're going to do on this
one before we start though we do need to
go ahead and grab our data and set that
up and so you can do it a number of
different ways we could do comma
separated we're going to switch it up a
little bit on this one because it's just
fun to try different things and we're
going to do enter in in number of
objects in the list we're going to enter
each of those values into our array and
our array we're just going to input an
integer of them print the original list
this should be pretty familiar because
we've done so many inputs in this lesson
in the last lesson all we're doing on
this one is we're just appending the
input here and how many inputs and still
going down the list and if we go ahead
and just run this first piece of code
real quick number of objects in the
input we'll do three values of the
objects we'll do three two five and you
can see here's our original series three
two five pretty basic and
straightforward and because uh for me
space is a commodity as far as our
output and the screen I have for your
catching you and what you're reading
there we'll just put it on one line
we'll say original list so the first
thing we want to do is if we're going to
do partitions let's create a module for
partitioning out our data and so we'll
start with a simple definition procedure
and we'll call it partition and we want
to take our list that it's sent we want
a low value a high value and what we're
going to do with this is we're going to
create I equals low minus 1. so remember
this is an index and we actually started
with zero so now we're actually one less
than the index if we're initiating this
with zero on one end and the maximum on
the high end and we'll call it pivot and
the pivot is going to be a value we'll
set that list equal to our list of our
high index so remember high and lower
indexes I is an index pivot is a value
that's the actual value in this position
of whatever we send it so we're going to
send it two pointers low and high and
we're going to send it the list and when
we initiate this we usually we'll set it
up as a first entity which is index of
zero for low and then for a high we'll
have the highest index on there then we
need to go ahead and do for J in range
low comma high so we're going to go
through all the different values in
there and if list of J is less than or
equal to pivot then I equals I plus 1
but we like to do with the python way so
plus equals one now remember we
subtracted one up here so this is one
less than whatever index we sent it
which if we start with zero would be
minus one and this brings it back up to
zero so this is why we put this in here
at the top part I'm actually going to
stop here just for a second because
sorting is one of the most basic things
but it's very confusing as to why the
Sorting is so difficult and one of the
reasons it's so difficult is because if
I have the numbers three two one there's
so many different ways to sort this one
I could take and look at these two
numbers and if this value is higher than
this one I could swap them which would
then give me two comma three comma one
and then I can look at these two numbers
and if this is bigger then I can do swap
them and then I get 2 comma 1 comma
three and then I got to start over
because now the two and the one aren't
in order and so you can see with the
lengthy list whatever I do starts right
turning into factorials n factorial runs
and there's no real easy way around this
because if I put a reverse list three
two one it's going to maximize how many
runs it takes and so finding different
ways to sort the data depending on what
you're doing can be really confusing so
understanding just what's going on with
this particular sort we're doing helps
to start understanding where this
problem occurs and certainly there's
tools out there to sort it for you which
are already maximized sometimes you have
to sort on values that aren't you know
the value you're sorting on might be
different it might be instead of
starting on J it might be the remainder
of J divided by something or it might be
the percentage of J over another column
so being able to sort these things is
important and knowing how this works the
logic behind it is more important than
the actual coding at this point so we
get in here we go I equals I plus one so
remember that I put in this case we did
it somehow reverted there I plus equals
one and then we're going to do list of I
comma list of J equals list of J comma
list of I and this is just a cool python
way of swapping values you can see here
we have j i becomes i j so we're
literally we're swapping the values up
here as we go through this partition on
right here and this works on our
counting because we have I which right
off the bat is set to zero we have high
which is not the N value but one less
than the N value so our range of J is
going from 0 to not quite the last digit
and our I is going from we've added to
plus one and then it goes to the end
here so we have our list of I our list
of J and we swap them out depending on
if listed J is greater than pivot and we
can also do something like this here's
our pivot we'll just take our pivot out
up here so here we have our list of high
is going to be our pivot number that
we're switching around and we're just
iterating it through and swapping values
and then finally we'll go ahead and run
this one more time list of I plus one of
list of high equals list of high comma
list of I plus one so one last swap at
the end now if you're looking at I
equals low minus one let's do this this
is kind of fun to do clean up our code a
little bit I'm incrementing it right
here why I don't know I can increment it
right afterwards and it has the same
result of taking the minus 1 off of here
and just adding it after I need it and
this then carries down to here where I
have I plus 1 well I'm adding it at the
end so I don't need to add it again and
we simplify it down to I equals low
following our eyes through there we have
list of I list of J list of J list of I
swapping here's our increment and then
our final swap at the end and what we
want to go ahead and do is we just want
to return I plus 1. and so if we're
going to have our partition set up this
way we're returning the I plus 1 or in
this case just I we want to return I
carried it down forgot to carry it down
there we've taken our list we've swapped
it around because we're passing the list
we're passing actual list not just a
pointer to it and then we're going to
return the I so we know what we did and
so if you remember down there when I did
that example the first time through we
swap it around and then it comes up and
says oh okay we've already swapped the
high value all the way up to the right
hand side then we have to start over so
we'll go ahead and call this quick sort
and the quick sort is going to take the
list a low and a high just like we did
for our partition and what we want to do
that is if low is less than high then we
want to go ahead and partition the index
we fix
there we go so PT is a value from the
partition that's coming back that's what
this I returned and so we would go ahead
and partition our list and we have our
low and high value going in there if
we're going to partition our list once
we get the PT back we can go ahead and
do a quick sort on the same list low
comma PT minus 1. so it goes through the
list it moves the highest value to the
end and then we want to take that PT it
returns and we want to subtract 1
because we know where the high point is
so now we have a shorter list to go
through and we sort it from the other
end too we'll do a quick sort and we'll
do our list comma PT Plus 1 comma high
so we're coming out from the other end
so we're basically sorting the the list
going both directions on here so this is
our sort on this one we've now sorted
our list so we need to go ahead and call
that and we can simply call that let's
see oh we can print out the list let's
do this let's go print there's our
original list sorted list and we'll put
our little placeholder or you know what
we won't put a placeholder there we'll
just put a comma in and of course it
probably helps to actually return the
list so we'll go up here and do uh
return list that we've nicely sorted on
here and we'll come down here to this
part and do quick sort and we have our
list that we put in we're going to start
with a 0 for initiating it and then we
have our high value which is simply the
length of the list because that points
to it's actually a link to the list
minus one that's going to point to the
last index and then real quick before I
run this let's do some quick cleanup
here the original list and then we want
to create a second list which equals the
original and then we're going to print
our sorted list and we're going to send
it this information for our quick sort
so let's go and see what that looks like
let's go ahead and run this and we're
going to enter our number of values
we'll just do three and we're going to
enter in three two one let's open this
up so we can see what's going on down
here so here's our original list three
two one and you can see it's nicely
sorted one two three and if I was
testing this out I would enter in one
two three to see what happened I would
enter in two three one just some quick
changes to make sure it's sorting
correctly in fact let's go ahead and do
that real quick let's go ahead and enter
another list we'll do a four and I'll do
one two three four one two three four
sorts out as one two three four and I
actually know from doing these so many
times that that's more than enough on
these but just in case let's go two one
three four and one two three four there
we go quick sort for our list certainly
the questions we're going to ask in here
are very general with a few specifics
towards data science since that's the
main direction that Python's going in
and you'd want to expand your questions
for your interview depending on the
domain that you're using the python in
specifically let's dive in and get
started with some python interview
questions number one what is the
difference between shallow copy and deep
copy and you can see with shallow copy
we have object one which has child one
child two child three and so on and
object two which has child one child two
child three a deep copy creates a
different object and populates it with
the child objects of the original object
therefore changes in the original object
is not reflected in the copy copy dot
deep copy creates a deep copy shallow
copy creates a different object and
populates it with the references of the
child objects within the original object
therefore changes in the original object
is reflected in the copy copy.copy
creates a shallow copy and you can look
at this if we make a change to child one
it's only a pointer so if you make it in
object one and change the channel one
and object one it will also make that
change in object two number two how is
multi-threading achieved in Python oh
this is a good one with multi-processing
and multi-threading this question is
actually asking you do you know the
difference between multi-processing and
multi-threading and how multi-threading
Works multi threading usually implies
that multiple threads are executed
concurrently the python Global
interpreter lock doesn't allow more than
one thread to hold the python
interpreter at that particular point of
time so multi-threading in Python is
achieved through context switching it's
very different than multi-processing
which actually opens up multiple
processes across multiple threads so
multi-threading discuss the Django
architecture so the Django architecture
and the first thing to know is that the
Django is a web service way to build
your web pages basically and so when we
look at the architecture you can see
here we have a nice model drawn out
where the user initiates the Django
which initiates the URL which initiates
the view what they're going to view and
you have your model and your template so
the model of data whatever data model
you're pulling goes into the template
and then goes back up the pipeline to
the user and the important thing to note
is there's a template the front end of
the web page this is what they're going
to see there's a model the back end
where the data is stored so you can keep
the template and the looks and
everything looks the same but you can
swap out the underlying formation that
goes into that template then you have
your view which interacts with the model
and template and Maps it to the URL and
then the Django serves the page to the
user so your Django grabs it and says
okay thank you for the URL and here you
go user what advantage does numpy array
have over nested list so numpy is a
module you import almost always see
numpy import numpy as NP numpy is
written in C such that all its
complexities are backed into a simple to
use module list on the other hand are
dynamically typed therefore python must
check the data type of each element
every time it uses it this make number
arrays much faster than lists I would
also add in that numpy has a lot of
additional functionality that you don't
have in lists there's a lot of things
you can automate in the numpy quick flip
over to our jupyter notebook any IDE
will work if you're going to do a set of
interview questions to taking a quick
look at code is always important we have
our import and of b as NP we'll go and
import time here's our list list sub for
Iron Range of 100 and what we're doing
is we're going to time it so we're going
to create a list then we're going to
create a numpy zeros array and you can
see here look how quick you can create
this numpy zeros array here we are
appending one zero at a time for a
regular python list and here we are with
numpy they're all zeros and they're all
of type integer I believe it's either
float or integer on this I'd have to
actually do a type on it and then so if
we take in and we create a tl1 time
equals time and then we do for I and
range of 100 for J in range of 100 L of
I J equals L of i j plus five so we're
just doing a simple calculation on our
array and sub arrays this is an array of
rays and we'll do the same thing with
tl2 tl2 time dot time tl1 equals so here
we have our final time on that and then
we'll do this with an array array op and
this is what I really love a equals a
plus 10 and then you can just print it
right out so you can see right here with
the numpy array I'm doing the same thing
if I run this our time is significantly
different here we have 0.09 and 0.003 so
you can see that the time drops
significantly when you're running this
on a numpy array versus a list array
also important to note these times
aren't going to be they'll change each
time I run it depending on what I have
running in the background so there we go
number five what is pickling and
unpickling Macy's me how many times I
pickle and unpickle something converting
a python object hierarchy to a byte
stream is called pickling pickling is
also referred to as serialization
unpickling converting a byte stream to a
python object hierarchy is also called
unpickling unpickling is also referred
to as deserialization so if you just
created a neural network model you can
now save that model to your hard drive
pickle it and then you can unpickle it
to bring it back into another software
Pro program or to use at a later time
how is memory managed in Python number
six python has a private Heap space
where it stores all the objects the
python memory manager manages various
aspects of this Heap like sharing
caching segmentation and allocation the
user has no control over the Heap only
the python interpreter has the access
you have a nice little diagram here
here's your program there's your
interpreter we have our Heap memory
management on the garbage collector
going off of there number seven are
arguments in Python pass by value or by
reference arguments are passed in Python
by reference this means that any change
made within a function is reflected on
the original object so you can see here
def function of l l of 0 equals three L
equals one two three four function L
print L and you're going to get three
two three four because we've passed l in
there so it's a pointer here we have def
function l l equals three two three four
L equals one two three four or function
of L print L because in this function I
have assigned instead of operating on a
piece of L the list I've consigned a
whole new value to that list or L it
then at that points will create a new
object so if I make changes to the
object it's going to change it in the
outside the definition if I use a
variable and I assign it a completely
new value like L equals three two three
four that will not show up when you're
outside the function number eight how
would you Generate random numbers in
Python to generate not random numbers in
Python you must first import the random
module the random function generates a
random float value between 0 and 1. the
random range function generates a random
number within a given range and you can
see here one is the lower end tens the
upper end and step two so it'd be one
three five and so on as far as the
options in the random generation number
nine what does the double forward slash
operator do in Python the forward slash
operator performs Division and Returns
the quotient in float for example five
over two returns 2.5 to do a double
forward slash operator on the other hand
Returns the quotient in integer for
example 5 double slash returns two five
divided by 2 and you drop the 0.5 number
ten what does the is operator do the is
operator compares the ID of the two
objects and you can see in here where
list one equals brackets around one two
three list one equals list two equals
true and you have the double equals in
Python of course and you can do list one
is list two where list two equals one
two three is false list two is not the
brackets one two three it equals it but
it's not the brackets and if we do list
three equals list one then list one is
list three equals true number eleven
what is the purpose of pass statement
the path statement is used when there's
a syntactic but not an operational
requirement for example the program
below prints a string ignoring the
spaces and so here we have variable
equals simply learned we've added two
spaces in it for I and variable so it
goes through each eye if I equals space
do nothing else print I and then we'll
have the end equals bracket bracket and
they'll print out Simply learn now of
course you would probably write this if
I does not equal blank space print but
this would be another way you could do
that if you need a placeholder for that
first logical set or that first area you
can also do a function like this you
could do function whatever your def
function name brackets colon pass so it
goes into the function and does nothing
but it's a placeholder number 12 how
will you check all the characters in a
string are alphanumeric python has an
inbuilt method is all number which
returns true if all characters in The
String are alpha numeric and so you can
see here a b c d one two three is all
number output equals true and the second
line a b c d the at symbol one two three
the pound symbol is all new output
equals false so I really just want to
know about is all new all numerical
alphanumerical number 12. how will you
check if all characters in a string are
alphanumeric so here we go if you know
is all a number which returns that the
characters in The String are
alphanumeric one can also use rejects
instead and so we have Boolean re match
what's important about this is to note
your capital a dash to capital z a
lowercase to dash to Z 0 to 9 means that
that array includes all of those the way
they have it written out plus a dollar
sign and then we have what we're
comparing it to the string we're
comparing to the ABCD one two three and
so we can do an re dot match and if it
matches if all these things if all the
different entities in that array matches
the first one we get an output true and
if not an output false now number 13 how
will you merge elements in a sequence
sequence there are three types of
sequences in Python there's lists tuples
and strings python equation makes this
easy if we have a list one and list two
and list one is square brackets one
comma two comma three list two is four
five and six we can simply do list one
plus list two and our output is one two
three four five six if we have tuples
your Tuple is the curve brackets
designates it and again just add them
together same thing with strings we have
simply learn S1 plus S2 equals simply
learn number 14 how will you remove all
leading white space in a string python
provides the inbuilt function L strip to
remove all leading access from a string
and you can see here space space python
dot L strip leading strip Python and you
can also do strip which releases leading
and ending of course there's also the
ending set number 15 how will you
replace all occurrences of a substring
with a new string the replace function
can be used with strings for replacing a
substring with a given string syntax
string.replace old comma new comma count
replace returns a new string without
modifying the original string hey John
how are you John question mark replace
John with capital j o h n one and then
you can see right here hey John how are
you and since we designated with the one
just says we're only going to replace
one of these 6
what is the difference between Del and
remove brackets on lists Del for delete
Dell removes all elements of a list
within a given range syntax Del list
start to end remove remove brackets
removes the first occurrence of a
particular character syntax list remove
element and we see a nice example over
here if we delete the list one to three
it will delete the first in this case b
one two it doesn't do three remember
that one two so it will delete B and C
and you end up with a d where if we do
remove B from the list and we have an a
b b d it's only going to remove the
first B number 17 how to display the
contents of text file in reverse order
open the file using the open function
store the contents of the file into a
list reverse the contents of the list
run a for Loop to iterate through the
list number 18 differential between
append and extend of pin adds an element
to the end of the list you can see right
here we have a list one two three four
and we have pin four and we end up with
an output one two three four and extend
adds an element from an interval to the
end of the list and we have here list
equals one two three list dot extend
four five six output is one two three
four five six so if you want to append
an array to the end of another array you
want to use the extend number 19. what's
the output of the below code justify
your answer this is a great interview
question because these are the kind of
things that come up when you're proofing
code def add to list value and list so
we have value in and a list in or List
equals an empty in this case an empty
list list data pin value return list
list one equals add to list one list two
equals add to list one two three empty
bracket list three equals add to list a
and then we want to print them list one
equals and you can see the formatting we
have our place holder list one list two
and list three so when it prints list
one we get one comma a and what you want
to notice here is that list one and list
three are equal why are they equal well
when we passed the information to the
add to list we passed value without
passing the list equals brackets without
passing a second value what this means
is that list as we have it if you don't
have a list it'll start off with empty
list which we append the one two the
second one list two we appended a value
to an empty list so it's only going to
be one two three doesn't matter what the
list was before we've already assigned
an empty list and then list three here's
the tricky one we're adding a to the
list but because we didn't designate the
list list is a shared value in other
words it doesn't reset it and we end up
with list one equals list three one
comma a default list is created only
once during the function and not during
its call number number 20 what is the
difference between a list and a tuple
lists are mutable while tuples are
immutable and you can see an example
down here where I have list equals one
two three square brackets denote it's a
list list of two equals four and I
printed out I now have one two four if I
do the same thing with the Tuple I get
an error because you can't change the
Tuple one two three into one two four
you have to completely reassign Tuple to
a new value what is Doc string in Python
doc strings are used in providing
documentation to various python modules
classes functions and methods and so you
can see here we have def for a function
add a b and this is a doc string we have
the triple brackets on there you can add
carriage return in that so that you can
go multiple lines and it says this
function adds two numbers and then sum a
b returns some and so we have down here
two different ways of accessing this
function output accessing docstring
method one this function adds two
numbers accessing Docs string method 2
help on function add in model main this
function adds two numbers and so you can
see the code down here has two very
different in values the second one is
basically a help menu there's our help
menu number 22 how to use print without
the new line the solution to this
depends on the python version you are
using in Python version 2 you can do
print Hi and then you add a comma
afterwards print how are you and you
have Hi how are you in version 3 print
hi comma end equals and it'll add a
space on the end there you can put
different characters in there but
generally just want to put a space to
put a space on the End Print how are you
and now we get Hi how are you number 23
how do you use the split function in
Python the split function splits a
string into a number of strings based on
a specific delimiter so we have string
split delimiter comma Max the maximum
number of splits the character based on
which the string is to split by default
is space so here we have an example we
have a variable red blue green orange
and we want to split it by commas and we
only want to do the first two so if we
print the list now you'll find it has
red blue and only spread it split it the
first two times and it gets to the third
one and just groups them all together
green and orange if you leave the two
off you'll split the whole thing number
24 is python object oriented or
functional programming python follows
object oriented Paradigm and you should
really know in depth what they mean by
object-oriented Paradigm if you're doing
any interview for scripting languages
python allows the creation of objects
and is manipulation through specific
methods it supports most of the features
of oops which as inheritance on a
polymorphism so you have an object and
you can inherit all the traits of that
object and then add new traits in or
alter some of those traits that's what
object oriented means python follows
functional programming Paradigm
functions may be used as first class
object python supports Lambda functions
which are characteristic of functional
Paradigm so you can set a variable to a
function as opposed to setting it to an
object number 25 write a function
prototype that takes variable number of
arguments here we have def function name
list so we could have in this case
whatever the list is Def function the
asterisk denotes so we're going to take
multiple arguments of a variable and we
can do for I and VAR print I so if you
send function of one you'll end up with
a one function one two five six it'll
actually print those out one at a time
the first one just prints out a one
because it only sent one variable the
second one will print one another line
25 another line 6. number 26 what is
asterisk args and asterisks quarks args
used in function prototype to accept
varying number of arguments it's an
iterable object death function arcs and
you can imagine it's just a basic list
so if I send add the numbers a comma b
or a comma B comma C it doesn't really
matter it will have that number of
objects in it whatever I send to it and
there's other uses for it but that's
very basic quarks I can actually tell it
what I want to send so using a function
prototype and to accept varying number
of keyworded arguments it's in both our
iterable objects so you can go through
them one at a time and the def function
chords you can now set like color equals
red units equal two so you'll see that
especially in machine learning there's a
lot of like they'll have inline equals
true that kind of thing number 27 in
Python functions are first class objects
what do you understand from this this
means I could return a function it could
be from another function I could create
a function and treat it just like an
object I can assign it to a variable I
can pass them as arguments to other
functions number 28 what is the output
of print nay underscore underscore name
justify your answer the double
underscore name double unders score is a
special variable that holds the name of
the current module program execution
starts from main or a code with zero
indentation thus double underscore name
double underscore name has a value
double underscore main double underscore
in the above case if the file is
imported from another module then double
underscore name underscore double
underscore holds the name of this module
number 29 what is a numpy array and we
briefly touched numpy array compared to
a list early in processing speed now
let's go ahead and look at some of the
more specifics a numpy array is a grid
of values all of the same type so if
they're either all float all integer all
string and is indexed by a tuple of
non-negative integers the number of
Dimensions is the rank of the array and
the shape of an array is a tuple of
integers giving the size of the array
along each Dimension number 30 what is
the difference between matrices and
arrays a matrix comes from linear
algebra and is a two-dimensional
representation of data it comes with a
powerful set of mathematical operations
that allow you to manipulate the data in
interesting ways now arrays an array is
a sequence of objects of similar data
type an array within another array forms
a matrix like we said here
two-dimensional so if you have an array
of three by four that would be a matrix
number 31 how to get indexes of n
maximum values in a numpy array of
course the first thing to do is to
import your numpy as NP you don't
necessarily have to use MP but that is
the most standard use of numpy we create
our array equals an NP dot array of one
two three four five and then if we want
to get our indexes of n maximum values
in an empty array we can do one way to
do it is to take our array sort it then
do minus n colon that means we're going
to do once you've sorted it you can do
minus in in would equal then the number
of indices so it's not the actual letter
N colon and really this is about
understanding this notation that we can
sort it so it goes from lowest to
biggest and then we can get the top
values for n indexes and then we have
our final set of brackets with the minus
one on there number 32 how would you
obtain the resulting set from the train
set and the test set from below and
let's go ahead and look at the two
different variables we have train set
equals an array of one two three test
set equals a numpy of Ray of arrays we
have 0 1 2 1 2 3. what's important here
is that one it's a numpy so that leaves
a out and then we're stuck with three
other options and I'm going to say that
e is out none of these and let's look at
NP dot concatenate versus NP dot v stack
concatenate would put one set after the
other so you would end up with probably
give you an error because one set is one
two three and then we're going to
concatenate array 0 1 2 and and one
array one two three the array of arrays
onto the end of that what we really want
to do is stack and by the ways you can
actually switch there's variables you
can put into concatenate obviously that
can change this so you could use the
concatenate with a lot of fudging around
but really what we're looking for is
v-stack v stands for vertical versus the
H deck which is horizontal and if we do
a v stack we can simply do train set
comma test set and stack them together
and so we have C resulting set equals
np.v stack train stack test set both
option A and B would do horizontal
stacking but we would like to have the
vertical stacking option she does this
again you could add the axes in and use
the concatenate to stack it the correct
way number 33 how would you import a
decision Tree classifier in sklearn we
have
sklearn.decisiontree import decision
tree classifier from sklearn Ensemble
import decision tree classifier and we
look at these and they're all import
decision tree classifier that actually
have last part happens to be correct and
it's really just a vocabulary knowing
where is the decision tree classifier
stored what module is that a part of and
it is of course part of the sklearn.tree
number c number 34 you have uploaded the
data set in CSV format on Google
spreadsheet and shared it publicly how
can you access this in Python what's
important here is to know that we can
read stuff with pandas so we don't show
it here but you can there's actually a
number of ways to do this what's
important here is to know a couple
things one we have our link generated
from the Google Docs and spreadsheets
and then we can do a string IO dot
string IO request get link dot content
so there's our source and then finally
we know that pandas can read a CSV
there's obviously many ways to read a
CSV but data equals pd.read underscore
CSV Source number 35 what is the
difference between the two data series
given below below we have DF name and DF
location colon comma brackets around
name comma where and then we have DF
equals PD data frame a b b x x u u comma
21 1650 33 columns equal name and age so
let's take a look and see what they're
looking at we have just glancing at the
questions they want to know is it the
original data frame or is it the copy of
the data frame and you can see here that
one is view of the original data frame
and two is a copy of the original data
frame two is a view of the original data
frame and one is a copy the original
data frame both are copies both are
views and if you're working with pandas
you know that unless you specifically in
certain things tell it to do it inline
and a lot of functions don't allow you
that you're always taking a slice and it
is always a copy so C both are copies of
the original data frame number 36 you
get the following error while trying to
read a file temp.csv using pandas which
of the following could correct it so
here's our error Trace back most recent
call last file input Line 1 and module
Unicode encode error ASCII codex can't
encode character oh I hate it when that
one comes up and we have four different
entries we'll go ahead and just pretend
that D doesn't exist unless we really
can't fit it into one of the other
answers and the first one is PD read CSV
has our file compression equals gzip
well gzip is just an unzipping and you
actually get a zip error on there the
second one is dialect equals string
again not an encoding or coding setup
and then we have encoding equals utf-8
well that would be the encoding error
switching it from the character code
there's utf-8 there is Unicode that's
the most common two that goes between so
really this is about understanding the
difference between a utf-8 coding and a
unit code and the error that comes up
quite regularly with that number c
encoding should be utf-8 number 37 how
to set a line with any plot given below
so looking at this we have import
matplot Library Pi plot is PLT and you
should know your way around this how to
do a plot in there
plt.plot1234 plot equals show so this is
a little bit of a vocabulary test the
vocabulary is at width equals three line
width equals three LW equals three or
something else and the vocabulary word
that we're looking for is LW equals
three which stands for line width in pi
plot Library Pi plot Number 38 how would
you reset the index of a data frame to a
given list so this is a vocabulary
Challenge and understanding what
re-indexing is re-indexing as we have
the different values here we have the
first one which is reset the index well
we're not really resetting the index
re-index number b means we're double
checking our indexes to the column and
to the main index and so the values
match correctly where re-index like now
brings in a new index outside of our
data Frank to a given list so this is
coming from external and thus the
vocabulary word like is our key word
that it's external and we have a data
print into a given list number 39 how
can you copy objects in Python the
functions used to copy objects in Python
we have copy copy for shallow copying
and copy deep copying for deep copy
number 40 what is the difference between
range and X range functions in Python
well this is a good one we have matrixes
and arrays with a matrix the range
returns a python list object X range
returns an X range object and with
arrays an x-ray returns an X range
object X range creates values as you
need them through yielding the key here
is that X range Returns the values as
you need them so it actually processes
it post like if you have for x or for a
variable in X range it is processing
them as you need them zero to nine it
doesn't create an array zero to nine it
just hands 0 then 1 2 3 4 1 at a time
number 41 how can you check whether a
panda's data frame is empty or not the
tribute df.empty is used to check
whether a panda's data frame is empty or
not and so you can simply create a we
have done here import our pandas is PD
we create our pandas data frame equal to
an empty array and is DF dot empty comes
out as true one of the catches you got
to remember with these vocabularies is
with empty along with some other pandas
set up whether you need the brackets or
not at the end number 42 write the code
to sort an array in numpy by the N minus
1 column this can be achieved using ARG
sort function let's take an array X then
to sort the N minus one column the code
will be X to X to colon n minus two dot
args sort so let's see what that code
looks like we import numpy as NP we'll
create our array our numpy array which
is uh one two three zero five two two
three four so we have three different
entities with three different columns in
there and we go X of X and so we take X
of all the rows first entity well in
this case it's actually the second one
because it's zero one two dot ARG sort
so that would be the second entity or
minus two would also be the same you
could also do instead of one you could
also do minus two there instead of the
one ARG sort and then we get an output
of the array one two three zero five two
two three four number 43 how to create a
series from a list numpy array and
dictionary so we'll go ahead and input
import our numpy or pandas and have my
list and you can see here we have my
list equals list of ABCDEFG over all the
way through so my list now makes a list
of that for array we have NP dot a range
to 26 my dictionary will create a
dictionary with a zip my list my
arguments so I'll just use the numpy
array we just created with my array to
go into the dictionary and the solution
is simple with the PD dot series my list
pd.series my array PD dot series my
dictionary so it's all about knowing the
dot Capital s-e-r-i-e-s don't forget
that capitalization number 44 how to get
the items not common to both series a
and series B and you can see here we
have instead of series A and B we have
series one and two and we have one two
three four five four five six seven
eight the solution is we take a panda
series we have a series U equals a panda
series NP Union one dimension series one
series two so we can now make a union of
them we now have series one Panda series
with an intersection and then we can
remove one from the other series U is
series U dot is in series one so if the
union is not in the intersection then
you know it's a unique value a little
bit of logic going on there and playing
with three different terms to get the
answer we want 45 how to keep only the
top two most frequent values as it is
and replace everything else as other in
a series so again we're working with
pandas because if you're talking series
and data frames that means we're working
with pandas so we're going to import
pandas as PD we'll go ahead and create
our Panda series we're going to do that
by creating a numpy random random State
100 so 100 in the numpy one and then we
have our Panda series you can see here
where random integer numpy random random
integer one comma five by twelve and so
the solution for this is we go ahead and
we've created a PD remember the capital
S Series solution we're going to print
the top two frequencies and that is our
series dot value counts and then we take
series values count dot index of up to
two so we're going to take everything up
to two and then we'll do the series is
in so if it's not in the first two then
it's going to equal other and this would
be something you'd want to write down on
paper if you're if it looks confusing
take a moment pause the video write this
down and see if you can figure out how
the logic came together and try to throw
yourself a couple other little logic
puzzles like this number 46 how to find
the positions of numbers that are
multiples of three from a series and in
here we're actually going to use a numpy
to solve it the first part series lets
you know it's going to be a panda series
and if we come down here we have NP dot
ARG where this is a vocabulary question
series with remember the percentile 3 is
the remainder so if the remainder equals
zero then we're going to generate that
ring where the object divided by three
equals zero has no remainder so that we
know it's a multiple of three number 47
how would you compute the euclidean
distance between two series and this
one's really cool because we have our
Panda series uh p and Q and what I like
about this one is they give us two
solutions you can go with and really you
should kind of know both the first one
would be yes you know what the euclidean
distance is and that is we can take the
first series minus the second series
squared and then sum them up and then we
do the square root which is the same as
taking the power to 0.5 doing the power
to 0.5 is easier than doing the square
root so a lot of times you'll see that
as a switch but you could have also done
the square root and use the math in
there so there's solution one you should
know your euclidean distance and then
solution two is the numpy solution so we
have NPA dot
linag.norm that's how we're going to
compute our euclidean distance
P minus Q very elegant and very
straightforward and easy to compute
number 48 how to reverse the rows of
data frame so here we have our data
frame we're going to create a numpy
array by 25 reshape it five minus one
when this creates a 25 by 25 data frame
and so our solution is to do the DFI
location and this is just understanding
how steps work the steps you have your
colon colon -1 so we're taking all the
rows all the columns minus one so our
stepping -1 going the reverse Direction
and then we're just going to use across
all the different columns on there let
me say that again the first colon is
going to be your row starting row
stopping row step minus one that's all
this is about is that step minus one
comma and then all the columns 49 if you
split your data into train test splits
is it possible to overfit your model and
the answer is yes is definitely possible
one common beginner mistake is retuning
a model or training new models with
different parameters after seeing his
performance on the test set my favorite
example of this is you have your script
put together and you keep hitting the
rerun button until you get the answer
you want not taking the answer it first
gave you or running it over an array and
recording all the answers to see how
they vary number 50 which python library
is built on top of matplot library and
pandas to ease data plotting the answer
this is Seaborn Seabourn is a data
visualization library in Python that
provides a high level interface for
drawing statistical information
informative graphs we've covered 50
different questions that might come up
on an interview hopefully you've taken
the time to note the vocabulary where
you're sticking and not having problems
you might have to go back and reluct up
v-stack versus eight stack versus
concatenate and also review the axes on
those little things like that also we
address some Logics how do you formulate
those different polls from a pan and as
data frame so that you're looking at the
right data with the minus one step or on
the NP array how we did brackets and
really fiddled with it I want to thank
you for visiting us today and joining us
for today's python questions for
interviews again my name is Richard
kirschner with the simply learned team
for more information visit
www.simplylearn.com or feel free to
leave a comment down below and we will
be monitoring that again thank you for
visiting and happy learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here